Guten Morgen Linus. Guten Morgen. Tim. Gute Nachrichten. Heiko Bars ist nicht mehr Justizminister.
Es sind auch keine guten Nachrichten. Wir können auch keine guten Nachrichten sein, wenn die einzige Möglichkeit inkompetente Akteure unschädlich zu machen ist, sie nach oben weg zu befördern.
Lokbuchnetzpolitik Nummer zweihundertsiebenundvierzig vom dreizehnten März zweitausendachtzehn frisch aufgetischt hier in der Meta-Ebene. Für euch,
und ähm ja, die Nuss ist da, hallo die Nuss.
Hallo.
War eine abwechslungsreiche Woche, oder?
Es war eine abwechslungsreiche Woche. Äh wollen wir erstmal kurz aufs Feedback noch eingehen.
Das können wir machen. Wir können uns hier auch erstmal mit Geplänkel anfängen fangen, aber ich bin ja ganz aufgeregt, ne? Wirklich?
Ach so, ja, können wir auch. Äh ich bin ja ganz aufgeregt noch. Ja, ich äh hatte ja die große große Ehre mit der Staatsministerin für Digitales in der Bahn zu sitzen.
Das hast du aber auch erst später gemerkt.
Das habe ich erst später gemerkt. Ja, also das war eine ein sehr komisches Vorkommnis. Äh muss ich irgendwie so, weiß ich gar nicht. Also wir haben in der letzten Sendung eigentlich absichtlich diesen ganzen Flugtaxiunsinn ausgeblendet
weil das ja also weil wir bemüht waren.
Mit dem Thema auseinanderzusetzen, dass die gute Frau Bea behandeln soll und äh während wir die Sendung aufgenommen haben, war eigentlich auf Twitter gerade schon so ha ha ha, Flugtaxi, äh weil äh sie da in der,
nicht heute scheuen heute Nachrichten. Ähm von der, ja war das Karen Mioska.
Keine Ahnung, ich hab's nicht.
Fernsehen.
Relativ äh scharf befragt wurde, was sie sich denn hier vorstellt. So, mit Digitalisierung und so. Und äh,
Büro Tibär sagte dann ja, also Breitband gäb's ja jetzt schon in dem Gewerbegebieten und jetzt müsste man eben die Infrastruktur für Flugtaxis bauen
das wurde natürlich rauf und runter gelacht in den sozialen Netzwerken und Flugtaxi war jetzt irgendwie das zu reiten der Hashtag ja.
Ich fand das so ein bisschen also man merkte es war natürlich ein bisschen traurig zu sehen, dass sie da im Fernsehen war und nicht wirklich ein sinnvolles Konzept vorlegen konnte und dann irgendwie dieses Flugtaxi Unsinn da reden musste, aber.
Seit ein paar Jahren im Verkehrsminist.
Die ist erst seit ein paar Jahren im Verkehrsministerium. Kein Mensch hat auch muss man Disney tatsächlich nachher aufgefallen. Ähm Dorothee Bär war vorher nie,
bei Logbuchnetzpolitik Thema. Ich glaube nicht, dass der Name überhaupt in einer unserer Sendung jemals gefallen ist.
Glaube ich auch nicht.
So und wir sind ja eigentlich hinterher, alles was in irgendeiner Form in der im entferntesten mal durch Relevanz oder Kompetenz,
positiv oder negativ auffällt in der Sendung zu behandeln und ich sinnierte so darüber, dass ich dachte so ja
Also außer, dass sie irgendwie Mitglied in diesem Verein Knetz ist, der bei uns auch wenig Erfahrung äh wenig Erwähnung findet.
Kennst du nicht Knetz.
Doch. Aber ich bin noch nicht auf die Idee gekommen, das so auszusprechen. Ja.
Nee, Klett. Ähm.
Ich bin auch noch so alt für mich, sie hat zehn jetzt noch ein Mobilfunknetz.
Genau, so haben wir, als sie gegründet wurden, haben wir, genau, das, das ist ein Verein, der auch so häufig von sich äh von sich hören macht, dass wir ihn seit seiner Krönung nicht mehr erwähnt haben. Das ist der Digitalverein, der Christdemokraten und Christsozialen.
Der sich nach dem analogen Mobilfunknetz nennt.
Der neunziger Jahre benannt hat, ja. Achtziger, neunziger Jahre, ne.
Das war's gar nicht, was ist jetzt los, aber im wesentlichen war das so das, was in den Acherzigern Anfang der neunziger Jahre Realität war, bevor dann die Dähnetze kamen.
Und die kamen dann halt so vierundneunzig fünfundneunzig äh ging das irgendwie los mit äh Telekom,
dann die zwei meines Mannes heute Vodafone Plus kam dann heute U2 et cetera.
Eingeführt neunzehnhundertvierundachtzig, das Szene und äh ja ähm einen neunzehn vierundachtzig eingeführt, ja, auf.
Achtzig sogar. Ja okay, gut. Aber da war das halt, okay, da war das so. Damals sollte man das noch Autotelefon.
Ja, weil diese Dinger konntest du kaum in Handygröße bauen, ne.
Also Anfang der Neunziger gab's halt dann diese Pockies, also die ersten halbwegs tragbaren SEL, et cetera, die hatten dann so so Monster äh Funkgeräte
die so halbwegs gingen, das Pocky, das war noch so ein kleiner Tragekoffer, so groß wie so eine fette Laptoptasche, die man halt mit sich rumschleppen musste,
Ja und dann wurde das halt mit dem Dehn jetzt abgelöst. Aber wir schweifen ab.
Ein Zell, ein Zell, Saliu Network, aber im Analog, ja? Also.
Aber immerhin nur noch eine,
nur noch eine Telefonnummer, unabhängig davon, wo du warst, ne? Das B-Netz vorher, da musstest du noch wissen, wo jemand ist und so, das war äh ne, das war so die, ich weiß gar nicht, ob's auch wirklich ein richtiges, wird wahrscheinlich auch mal ein A Netz gegeben haben,
Weiß ich aber jetzt.
Jahre, fünfziger, fünfziger, siebziger Jahre irgendwie sowa.
Das war dann wahrscheinlich eher nur so in Regierungskreisen und der Hochfinanz äh ne aber egal.
Fanden wir lustig, Zenetz, okay, meinetwegen Doro Bär ist, um mal jetzt ein paar Klammern geschlossen zu bekommen. Teil davon und das war so dieses oh, es gibt sogar in der CSU Leute, die wissen, wie man Twitter bedient, ne.
Das ist hier auf jeden Fall so für für die für die CSU absolute äh Speerspitze des der Modernit.
Wegen hat sie sich halt auch automatisch qualifiziert, weil kein Computer ein und ausschalten und kein Füßer bedienen, muss er halt dann irgendwie auch für Breitband zuständig sein.
Ja, jetzt ist die Staatsministerin und wir wir haben hohe Hoffnung, dass sie dem Breitbandausbau in Deutschland vorantreibt.
Ich würde sagen, wir haben Erwartungen. Erwartungen. Wir haben hohe Erwar.
Erwartungen ja. Wir haben hohe Erwartungen und diese das mit den Flugtaxis wird auf jeden Fall in den dreieinhalb Jahren, die dieser Koalition noch bleiben, auch ein ambitioniertes Versprechen.
Und ich habe auch überhaupt nichts dagegen, dass ich ähm Politiker auch, sagen wir mal, Innovationen, auch wenn das jetzt an der Stelle ja mit
Breitband nix zu tun hatte, ja? Das ist das Verstörende daran, ne. Grundsätzlich ist okay, ne?
Nur die Viabilität von Flugtaxis oder sagen wir mal auch nur die Relevanz dieses Themas für die nächsten fünf Jahre, wo andere Sachen doch jetzt erstmal wichtiger sind, sehe ich es nicht. Nicht, dass man sich darüber hinaus,
denken, nachdenken könnte, aber äh ehrlich gesagt, ich denke lieber über Weltraumfahrstühle nach, als über äh fliegende.
Wenn sie jetzt Weltraumfahrschul gesagt hätte, wäre sie genauso ausgedacht geworden. Ich ähm würde, also mich hat daran gestört, äh also diese ganze Flugtaxi-Nummer, das das hat mich in Vamir ein bisschen zu doof
ja und deswegen haben wir das hier in der Sendung nicht behandelt, sondern haben uns eben damit auseinandergesetzt, wie wie sie da jetzt positioniert ist und so weiter. So.
Dann äh Tag später oder zwei sitze ich in der Deutschen Bahn, äh wie ist ja so häufig mein Schicksal ist und ähm fahre mit dem ICE.
Und äh war eigentlich auf dem Weg zu einem Termin
und ähm dann ist es zu einem sehr äh traurigen Fall gekommen, denn dieser Zug äh hielt mit einer sehr starken Bremsung an und ich saß äh vorne in dem Zug und habe das auch.
Gehört und verstanden, was da passiert ist, noch bevor es dann auch durchgesagt wurde ähm und dann kam die Durchsage des ähm ja wie halt, ich glaube, die heißen Zugführer, also die Betreuer quasi der.
Zugführer.
Man würde jetzt sagen, der Bahnchef, also für die eine Bahn, der Zug.
Chef ja Zugchef oder.
Chef und der sagte, was ich überraschend fand, also die Deutsche Bahn hat ihre Informationspolitik,
Offenbar innerhalb des letzten Jahres geändert, denn man bekommt, also mir fällt jetzt immer wieder auf, dass es sehr konkrete Ansagen gibt dazu, was gerade passiert ist und mit was für Verspätungen zu rechnen ist.
Die Durchsage lautete Inhaltsgemäß irgendwie so ähm ja meine Damen und Herren ähm
Wie sie bemerkt haben, ist der Zug zum Stehen gekommen. Ähm es hat sich eine Person im Gleisbett befunden, der Schaffner, also der Zugführer ähm war nicht mehr in der Lage,
zu bremsen.
Fahren. Zum Bremsen. Ach so.
Ähm die Person wurde jetzt überfahren und ähm,
Wir warten jetzt, wir haben jetzt die Rettungskräfte informiert und wir werden jetzt warten müssen und ähm sie können sich äh.
Darauf einrichten, dass das jetzt sehr lange dauern wird. Ähm rechnen sie bitte mit erfahrungsgemäß mindestens zweieinhalb Stunden Verspätung, die sie ab jetzt.
Haben werden. Ähm Grund dafür ist, ne, der äh es kommt quasi
Rettungskräfte, Polizei, es kommt dann das äh von der Bahn unterhaltenden Notfallmanagerteam. Die müssen dann diese Unfallstelle natürlich irgendwie aufnehmen
die Bahnstrecke wieder freigeben und der Zug, den kann's natürlich auch nicht mehr fahren. Ähm.
Das heißt, du wirst da abtransportiert und so. Das ist eine größere Angelegenheit. Und das hat er sehr äh sehr klar durchgesagt.
Du meinst der der Zug kann nicht selber fahren oder kann nicht.
Den kannst du nicht mehr fahren. Also den, der muss natürlich in eine Kontrolle und der muss auch in eine Reinigung.
Also der muss langsam gezogen werden, so.
Wird der Pferd nicht mehr. Also der steht.
Muss ja dann weg, also.
Der fährt dann irgendwann ohne Person, wird der dann da weggefahren so, aber.
Aber ihr musstet alle aussteigen, dann.
Wir mussten alle aussteigen. So und das hat das dauerte Stunden. So, jetzt standen wir also der Zug steht dann diese Linie. Das war die.
Es müsste, ich hab's jetzt nicht gesehen, also es war kurz hinter Berlin, das war glaube ich die neue ICE Ausbaustrecke, der ICE siebenhundert hast du nicht gesehen nach,
München,
und der Unfall war irgendwo bei Ludwigsburg. Also noch kurz hinter, kurz hinter Berlin. Also wir saßen da nicht lange drin, da war die die Reise vorbei und dann fielen natürlich auch alle anderen Züge, fielen aus, die diesen Streckenabschnitt fahren, weil.
Da ist halt jetzt der größere Einsatz. Jetzt habe ich zu dieser Art Einsatz eine ähm ein persönliches äh.
Persönliche Beziehung, weil ich früher Rettungssanitäter war. Ähm als Zivildienstleistender, also nicht lange,
Und ich hatte aber das große Glück, dass ich äh solche Einsätze nicht fahren musste. Ähm der Kelch ist an mir vorübergegangen.
Also hätte passieren können, ist.
Ja, das ähm ja ich habe mich da mit den mit den anderen äh Fahrgästen auch drüber unterhalten, weil einer fragte, na, wie oft passiert sowas wohl? Und die Antwort ist, äh, zweimal am Tag.
Im Schnitt. Also es sind über siebenhundert solche Fälle, die so in, im Schnitt im Jahr aufgezeichnet werden,
von ja in der Regel Menschen, die.
Nicht durch die da nicht unabsichtlich im Gleisbett sind. Und ähm das ist eine.
Wirklich äh ganz krasse Geschichte für alle Beteiligten, also für die äh für die Rettungskräfte, die dann da vor Ort gehen müssen. Das ist so, du musst also das muss natürlich.
Entfernt werden, der das sieht nicht schön aus ähm und ähm was bei den Rettungskräften.
Heißen diese Fälle. Da gibt's also im im Rettungsdienst hast du relativ viel Sarkasmus, um mit dem den Dingen, die dich da irgendwie, die du im Alltag da behandelst, äh irgendwie,
Zum Ausdruck zu bringen und der irgendwie bei bei uns im Rettungsdienst hieß das dann halt irgendwie so ja äh weiße RTW eins einmal Amputat äh Kopf ähm,
Bahnübergang so und so, ja? Äh, Amputatbeutel hast du natürlich nur für Finger, Arme und Beine, für den Kopf brauchst du den nicht.
Und solche Sprüche werden da halt geklopft, um irgendwie mit diese mit diesen enormen Belastungen umzugehen. Ähm die Deutsche Bahn hat wie gesagt in eigener Abteilung dafür mit den ähm mit den äh,
hier,
Schaffnern, also den Zugführern umzugehen, weil die ja in diesen weiß ich nicht wie viel Tonnen Stahl sitzen und die wissen ja, was jetzt passiert und die können, die sehen das ja, die können bremsen, aber.
Redest jetzt von den Lokführern.
Von den Lokführern, genau.
Führer ist tatsächlich von der Beschreibung her der Chef der Oberschaffner sozusagen.
Lokführer ist das, was ich sagen muss, soll.
Triebfahrzeugführer heißt es technisch äh genau.
Die Triebfahrzeugführer landen danach äh nicht selten in längeren ähm Seelsorgerprogrammen ähm um mit dieser Sache klarzukommen, mit für die Rettungskräfte ist das äh,
echt üble Belastung für alle Beteiligten. Äh ich habe da nachher auf Twitter meldete sich ein Zugführer, der sagte, dass üblicherweise so ein Fall,
so was wie einhundertsechzig Personen in Mitleidenschaft zieht im Sinne von ähm.
Also die äh Rettungskräfte am Ort. Polizei ist natürlich auch da äh Lokführer dessen Familie,
die damit dann kämpfen muss, dass sie jemanden hat, der auf einmal ins Leere blickt.
Und das ist also eine eine ganz, ganz, ganz fürchterliche Sache, wo ich äh wenig.
Wo ich kaum Humor verstehe, weil ich halt auch Leute gesehen habe, die sowas mal hinter sich hatten.
Und ähm ja, ziemlich üble Angelegenheit. Mir war da auch echt nicht zum zum Scherzen zu Mute, weil ich eben auch an.
An alte Erinnerungen so ein bisschen gedacht habe und ähm ja muss man äh muss man irgendwie mit umgehen. War auf jeden Fall jetzt echt nicht witzig.
Aber anderen war schon zum Scherzen zumute.
Doro Beer hatte natürlich ihr Hashtag Flugtaxi zu reiten,
und saß offenbar in diesem Zug, also ich saß da irgendwie auf den Schienen, das WLAN funktionierte äh und dann habe ich mir da habe ich mir halt Twitter angeschaut und nachdem ich meine Termine für den Tag abgesagt habe.
Du saßt auf den Schienen. Ach so, ihr wart schon.
Nein, der Zug hing auf den der Blick, der ist stehengeblieben. Der Zug stand da zwei Stunden.
Aber ihr, ihr wart im Zug.
Dann, also dann kommen so durch, dann kommen das Erste, was auch die also die Rettungskräfte, da sind natürlich sehr viele gekommen. Da ist dann auch erstmal so eine Reihe, die sind halt durch den ganzen Zug gegangen und haben geguckt, ob die Leute klarkommen.
Durch die Vollbremsung, auch unter Umstän.
Durch die also die Bremsung war jetzt nicht so stark, dass sie dich das aus dem Zug, also aus dem Sitz fliegst, aber.
Passieren, wenn du genau in der falschen Bewegung bis.
Genau, wenn der, wenn du gerade stehst, dass du da mal äh aus dem Tritt kommst, ähm dadurch, dass dann haben sie also Wasser verteilt und nicht alle kommen damit halt gut zurecht mit dem
wissen, was da gerade geschehen ist, ne? So, äh kümmern die sich drum.
Und ähm dann verteilt die Bahn äh Wasser und ne, waren also auch sehr bemüht, um das Wohlergehen ihrer.
Ihre Passagiere. So und dann Dorothee Bär war offenbar in dem gleichen Zug.
Und twitterte dann aus dem ein Foto aus dem Fenster von den Rettungskräften zu drei, vier, fünf, sechs, sieben, acht, um um die zehn Rettungskräfte,
An der Zahl, die da im Schnee drumherum stehen, ähm.
Die Rennen natürlich jetzt nicht als erstes nach hinten, wo die also die Unfallstelle liegt ja hinter dir. Da darfst du natürlich auch nicht sofort hin, weil erst die Bahn sicherstellen muss, dass da jetzt auch wirklich keine Züge mehr irgendwo fahren
weil jetzt die sich auch nicht darum reißen so, ne? Und weil du,
Weiß, da ist wahrscheinlich eh nicht mehr so viel zu machen. Ähm, so, also stehen die dann erstmal da rum, dann kommt der, muss da jemand die,
wie gesagt hat, ist kein kleiner Einsatz. Und Dorothee Beer fotografierte also so die Rettungskräfte, die da draußen irgendwie stehen und äh sich einen Überblick verschaffen und äh,
twitterte dann, wenn man mit der DB-Bahn gestrandet ist und weit und breit keinen Raute-Flugtaxi in der Nähe ist
denn sie muss ja ihr Flugtaxihashtag bedienen, mit dem sie da ja gerade äh mehr oder weniger eigentlich durch den Kakao gezogen wurde und dann bleibt ihr natürlich nichts besseres übrig, als ähm.
So ein, so ein Spruch. Ich meine, wenn du einen Hashtag pflegen willst, dann musst du halt auch über Leichen gehen, ne?
Da musst du halt Social Media Kompetenz zeigen. Und na ja, ich fand das irgendwie wirklich nicht besonders amüsant. Ähm viele andere auf Twitter auch nicht und sie fand sich dann in einer,
dann doch sehr ausführlichen Kritik wieder, die über sie hereinbrach, hat dann diesen Tweet gelöscht ähm.
Einer halben Stunde.
Nach einer halben Stunde, wobei ich jetzt auch sagen muss, der dann wurde der Wagen ja auch evakuiert.
Es kann also sein, dass sie das mit diesen,
erst so spät gemacht hat, weil sie gerade rauskratzeln musste aus der Bahn. Ähm interessant fand ich aber dann, dass sie.
Ich mein so ja hat sie sich halt vercheckt so, ist halt echt geschmacklos so, das ist wirklich geschmacklos und da sehe ich, habe ich auch überhaupt gar kein gar keinen Spielraum mehr für Humor, was ich aber dann echt,
Ziemlich übel fand ist, dass sie dann nachher behauptet hat, sie hätte erst später,
Verstanden, was überhaupt los ist. Also ihre Entschuldigung war irgendwie so, oh ich habe gerade erst gesehen, was hier passiert ist und ähm,
Die Bahn macht einen ganz tollen Job und FIFA Po und das nehme ich ihr halt leider nicht ab, weil es eben diese Durchsagen waren wiederholt, so und das verwirkt also diese Informationspolitik ist echt Durchsagen, was passiert, was hier eine Rolle spielt und,
Ich halte es tatsächlich für ausgeschlossen, dass sie das nicht mitbekommen hat, weil ich habe die besten Noiscansing-Kopfhörer, die der Markt hergibt.
Diese Bremsung und diese Durchsage waren
damit nicht ausblendbar. Und ähm spätestens, also entweder ist sie halt wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr schwer von Begriff, dass wenn da zehn, wenn du mitten auf der auf den Gleisen stehst und zehn Rettungskräfte
mehrere in mehreren Fahrzeugen um dein, um dein Zug tanzen, dass du da nicht verstehst
Was ich jetzt bei jemandem, der aus Süddeutschland kommt und in Berlin arbeitet und wahrscheinlich jeden Tag in der Bahn sitzt, mir schwer vorstellen kann.
Ähm ja oder sie hat da halt einfach irgendwie es mit der Wahrheit nicht ganz so genau genommen. Beides finde ich wirklich ähm.
Macht auf mich einen sehr, sehr schlechten Eindruck. Muss ich sagen.
Tja.
Das war meine Woche in Twitter. Und wie gesagt, ich verstehe da, also ich habe.
Wie gesagt in persönliche Beziehung zu dem Thema, dass was da vielleicht auch meine äh Resonanz ein bisschen äh,
anders aussehen lässt als die von anderen Menschen, aber äh sowas passiert tatsächlich nicht selten und ähm.
Es ist man kann nur ähm.
Ja hoffen, dass das weniger wird aus mehreren Gründen, ne? Ist auch irgendwie dramatisch, dass Menschen das überhaupt tun und ähm.
Wenn euch irgendwann mal der Gedanke kommt, äh redet bitte mit Leuten drüber, die euch helfen, diesen Gedanken nicht durchzuführen.
Und unabhängig jetzt von der,
Unabhängig jetzt von der von der von der von der Schwere oder wie viel versteht man jetzt Verständnis dafür, man jetzt aufbringen kann oder nicht,
jedem passiert's mal, mir ist es auch schon passiert, Gott sei Dank nicht so oft so, dass man sich so ein bisschen im Ton vergreift. Ja. In sozialen Medien. Ja
weil man grad was nicht gecheckt hat oder weil man grad, obwohl man's gecheckt hat, irgendwie kurzes Hirn im Regal gelassen hat, so weil man einfach irgend so ein so ein
so ein so ein vielleicht auch schon so eine eingespielte Routine auf einmal in einem hochkommt und vollkommen vergessen lässt, was gerade der der Kontext ist oder wie etwas von anderen äh verstanden werden kann.
Das ist das ist äh kann passieren so, ne. Aber da sollte man eben auch zusehen, dass man sich dann danach auch auch ehrlich macht,
Nur mal so als Tipp äh und sagt sorry war scheiße, gelöscht, via Kultur äh.
Ja, weil das Dümmste, was man dann machen kann, ist, irgendwie noch mit so,
Begründung daher zu kommen, weil diese Begründung zählen dem Moment nicht, falsch ist einfach dann dann falsch, ja? Und es interessiert dann auch niemanden, was
gerade dein Hirn äh falsch hat
abbiegen lassen, so, das war dann so, dann sagt man das auch so und dann macht man's klar, weil in dem Moment, wo man versucht, noch so weitere Relativierungen damit reinzubekommen, macht man's eigentlich nur noch schlimmer. Und das ähm ist,
kluge Maßnahme so und auch wenn so generell der der Ton da draußen rübelhaft ist uns leider viel zu viele Leute gibt, die einfach immer noch nicht verstanden haben, was sie da eigentlich tun äh im Netz oder drauf scheißen, muss man sich ja dem
holt nicht unbedingt noch anschließen und an der Stelle ist es sinnvoller einfach mitspiel voranzugehen.
Kleiner Sideplot, ähm sie äh also sie war ähm die, wenn ich das richtig sehe, die ja vorher im BMVI.
Und äh da als Koordinatorin der Bundesregierung für Güterverkehr und Logistik und deswegen meldete sich auch so.
VI, BMVI ist Verkehrsminister Infrastruktur, okay, erst klare.
Und so kam es dann auch, dass die Deutsche Bahn sich auf Twitter sofort bei ihr meldete, wie sie denn der Frau Bär helfen könnte. Ähm, ach so, um die, um die Story noch kurz zu Ende zu erzählen, weil äh also was dann passierte war.
Es rollte dann nach entsprechender Zeit ein anderer Zug neben unseren.
Und dann wurde unser Zug evakuiert und wir konnten dann alle aus einem Wagen und zwar einen Wagen, einen Ausgang äh über so eine Planke rüber in den anderen Zug,
Und dann wurde auch die Frage gestellt, äh warum machen die nicht einfach alle Türen auf?
Weil Freunde, wir mitten auf einem Gleisbett stehen und da halt so eine Planke gelegt wurde. Du hattest dann halt äh zwei Rettungskräfte auf jeder Seite, die dabei helfen, dass auch ne äh gebrechliche
Fahrgäste in diesem Schnee, in dieser Kälte, über diese Planke, von dem Einzug, in den anderen gehen und dass da keine Panik
passiert und dass da nicht noch fünf weitere Verletzte hast und dass einer sagt, ach der Zug ist auf der anderen Seite und so. Das ist äh so und dann wurden wir nach Ludwigs,
oder Ludwigsfeld oder wie der Bahnhof da hieß, ähm gefahren, das waren echt nur ein paar hundert Meter. Und da wurde wurden wir dann in Bussen,
im Busse verfrachtet und.
Also es war jetzt auch kein ICE, sondern irgend so ein.
Der Zug war ein ICE, aber der, der uns abgeholt hat, war eine eine Regionalbahn.
Das meine ich an der Regionalwahl ok.
Genau, das war eine Regionalbahn,
ähm privat betriebene Odek oder so und dann wurden wir dahin gefahren, dann konnten, dann gab's halt Busse zu unterschiedlichen Stationen. Also es gab irgendwie weiter im Streckenverlauf,
Bis zum nächsten größeren Bahnhof, wo du dann wieder in einen ICE einsteigen könntest, um die Fahrt nach München fortzusetzen und es gab auch, was weiß ich im Bus zurück nach Berlin für,
wie mich, wo sich der, wo jetzt eh alle Termine.
Dann durch war.
Durchfahren. Ja, das war so, dass da äh das Thema, wenn so etwas passiert.
Gut, schließen wir das an der Stelle ab, ja? Ja. Ja.
Ja. Lange genug drüber geredet.
Kommen wir dann zu etwas Feedback.
Stimmt ja.
Nicht so lang.
Heute mal nicht so lang. Ja, es wurde beklagt, dass wir ähm.
Witze über hundertsiebenundzwanzig null über das hundertsiebenundzwanzig null eins Ministerium machen und dann aber äh.
Es nicht schafften, auch wirklich das naheliegende abzukratz.
Ja, aber das ist, ich habe tatsächlich einen Grund, warum ich's nicht gemacht habe. Also, Mythos hat das kommentiert.
Ja ja ich.
Ich habe einen Grund.
Ja, wir haben denselben Grund nehmen, würde ich mal vermuten, ne? Also
Lora Akustik Kontext zu machen. Wir haben uns über Herrn Seehofer äh ein wenig äh beschwankt und ähm ne äh äh hast ja auch diesen schönen Clip gesehen, du das da jetzt auch noch über sich selber irgendwie äh wollte dann Heimatministerium sagen
im Fernsehen, hat aber Heimatmuskulatur gesagt. Also unser Heimatmuseumsminister.
Zuständig halt fürs Hochlokale und natürlich ist der Begriff Localhorst hier sehr, sehr, sehr naheliegend. Leider ist das halt schon,
ein ein besetzter Nick, der ihm irgendwie bei uns in der Clubcommunity und an dieser Stelle schöne Grüße an Local Horst sehr schade, dass wir das jetzt äh von Hoherstelle so streitig gemacht wird,
ähm aber äh das hat durchaus sagen wir mal den das Potential äh an der Stelle, die er vollständig genommen zu werden. Wir werden das jetzt hier nicht weiter betreiben und keinen Hashtag empfehlen
aber ja das hatte einen Grund.
Dann gab's hatten wir uns viele unterhalten darüber, wie man den Journalismus ähm.
Wie man wie der Journalismus damit zu kämpfen hat seine Einnahmen für seinen Betrieb zu sichern. Ja. Was hattest du da jetzt noch an Feedback äh gesehen.
Also wir haben glaube ich einfach das Thema nur so nebenbei behandelt. Es gab da noch ein paar Hinweise über AdBlocker, Methoden und Sonstiges. Ähm.
Wir haben da glaube, also ich würde einfach nur sagen, wir haben da jetzt nicht den, die abschließende Diskussion geliefert und vor allem nicht die Beste.
Aber ähm.
AD äh kommentierte dazu noch in der Diskussion zur Finanzierung durch Werbung, will ich den Aspekt des freien Zugangs nochmal etwas hervorheben. Der freie Zugang zu journalistischen Artikeln ist ein hohes Gut
Unsere ganze Idee vom aufgeklärten Nachrichtenkonsen basiert eigentlich auf der Annahme, dass Artikel frei zugänglich sind. Es ist umso unwahrscheinlicher, dass man Behauptungen über den Inhalt eines Artikels selbst.
Prüft, beispielsweise Wikipedia-Kleppquellenangaben. Wenn man dafür bezahlen oder eventuell
äh schon nur die Blockierung von Werbung abschalten muss. Zugeführt führen zu einem Wettbewerbsnachteil der dahinterliegenden Informationen und das ist natürlich ein sehr
ein sehr wichtiger Punkt, der ähm Kern dieser ganzen Websache ist,
weil wir erstmals durch dieses schöne World White Web äh die Situation hatten, dass eben diese Nachrichten,
In der schriftlichen Form archivierbar auch wirklich kostenlos öffentlich zugänglich sind. Ja? Früher, früher TM musste man sich die Zeitung oder das Magazin kaufen.
Oder in der Bibliothek oder bei Mikrofisch äh auslesen.
Über Microfish auslesen oder natürlich, es gab dann noch den mehr oder weniger kostenfrei zugänglichen ähm
Rundfunk, wobei jetzt haben wir schon, jetzt haben wir spätestens die die GEZ-Kritiker in den äh in den Kommentaren, aber es war nicht immer so, dass.
Hochqualitativer Journalismus. Erstmal prinzipiell frei zugänglich war.
Und das ist ein wichtiger Punkt und das äh wenn jetzt alle wieder auf Paywall und so weiter umschwingen und AdBlocker, Blogger und Hasse nicht gesehen, dann ähm.
Werden wir das Problem wieder zunehmend haben,
Dass äh diese diese Quellenprüfung und sonstige Vorgänge nicht mehr frei zugänglich sind, das heißt es gibt eine höhere Hürde und das ist schlecht und damit ist auf jeden Fall richtig gesagt, der freie Zugang ist ein hohes Gut und dafür sollten wir,
einstehen, das bedeutet aber auch, dass wir entweder uns mit dieser Werbegeschichte anfreunden müssen.
Oder dass wir als Gesellschaft da ja solidarischer, klarer wieder werden müssen und uns darüber,
in unserer eigenen kleinen Haushaltsfinanzplanung im Klaren sein müssen, dass wir solche Outlets die frei zugängliche.
Nachrichten ermöglichen äh in irgendeiner Form unterstützen. Hinter.
Ja und äh vielleicht in dem Zusammenhang ähm hatten wir glaube ich hier gar nicht erwähnt. Es gab ja letzte Woche eine Abstimmung in der Schweiz,
über äh ob denn nun wie hieß es nochmal, Bill No Bilder, Kissy Initiative, Belag ist so quasi die GEZ äh Systematik in der Schweiz und ähm,
aus dem wir nicht weiter überraschend festzustellen, äh rechten Lager, also da so diese wie heißt der mal, SV beziehungsweise nicht.
SVP, oder?
SVP wollte okay sagen, ich bin ein Na,
SVP und da die haben halt auch so eine Jugendorganisation und da gibt's dann halt auch äh solche Heißsporte, die das dann halt antreiben, ne. Das ist dann auch so ein bisschen so die.
AfD äh artige
Fraktion offensichtlich, weil das ist ja sozusagen das, was uns ja auch die Rechtspopulisten am laufenden Meter unterschieben wollen
Stichwort Lügenpresse und überhaupt und äh GEZ sei ja nun ganz schlimm, weil Zwangsgebühr und ne und
sorry, aber davon darf man sich wirklich überhaupt nicht anstecken lassen. Ganz im Gegenteil, wenn's nach mir geht. Also, ich meine, ich verstehe.
Die Problematik der GEZ zum Beispiel, um das jetzt mal auf Deutschland zu übertragen? Verstehe Aspekte davon, ja? Also jeder Haushalt muss zahlen
da kommt schnell dieses Argument, hm, na ja, aber wir gucken ja gar keinen X oder dieses und jenes, darum geht's halt nicht. Sondern es geht dadrum
dass wir ein öffentlich-rechtliches,
Nachrichtensystem haben, was eben unabhängig ist. Und auch diese Argumentation, das sei ja vom Staat kontrolliert, nur weil's ein paar Aufsichtsratsgremien gibt, wo irgendwie auch Politiker pro Ports betrieben wird, weil das ja jüngst dann auch von den Gerichten nochmal ein bisschen zurückgestutzt wurde,
Auch das äh ist halt eigentlich Quatsch, weil die die Realität ist, dass die Unabhängigkeit im öffentlich-rechtlichen äh Rundfunk.
Segment ist sehr hoch, ja,
viel höher als sie es im privat finanzierten Bereich ist, weil da regiert das Geld halt äh äh alles,
und das ist halt im öffentlichen Rundfunk ähm.
Nicht so. Nicht so. Ja, was dann und.
Schon, aber eben nur, weil eben eben nicht genug Geld dafür da ist. So, jetzt kann man natürlich lange darüber diskutieren, dass der Apparat aufgeblasen ist, dass er nicht effizient arbeitet und so weiter.
Alles vollkommen berichtigt, äh hätte ich auch 'ne Menge drüber zu klagen, nur die Antwort darauf ist halt nicht, dass man alles generell,
in Frage stellt, weil hätten wir nämlich die Situation andersrum, dass wir diesen Journalismus nicht haben, dann hätten wir so eine Situation wie äh in den USA,
ja, wo äh eben solche Sender wie Fox News äh entstehen,
wo einfach nur noch das Geld zählt und wer am meisten zahlt, der der setzt auch die Agenda und dann haben wir natürlich wirklich eine Agenda Dief.
Die Situation haben wir natürlich trotzdem schon, ne? Also es wird ja ohne ohnehin ein ein Scheiß in auch in unserem Fernsehen gesendet, äh die der auf keine Kuhhaut mehr geht, aber wir haben wenigstens noch ein
gegen Gewicht, dass in einer gewissen Form frei von ähm.
Von diesen kapitalistischen Kriterien ist und einen Bildungsauftrag im weitesten Sinne verfolgen kann und ähm das auch in den verschiedensten Formen immer wieder,
tut.
Und auch teilweise hervorragend macht, ja? Also wenn man nur mal sowas wie Kinderfernsehen der öffentlich rechtlichen kann ich nur mal einen Hut vorziehen, was
äh was da an Produktionen gemacht wird so
da muss man nur mal kurz zu RTL rüber schalten, wie die sich Kinderfernsehen vorstellen, ja? Das ist sozusagen eine einziges Schaulaufen von äh Kinderfettmachenden äh Produktkategorien. Das.
Wer gegen die GEZ kämpft, der hasst die Maus, den Elefanten und die Gans und den Armin und den Christoph.
Ende der Debatte.
Okay, also.
Ist für dich fast mein, mein, mein, mein Train of Sort, also immerhin, also in der Schweiz ist das abgewählt äh oder dagegen gestimmt.
Gewährt worden, kann man das.
Gewährt worden, genau äh mit wie ich finde recht relativ beruhigenden einundsiebzig Prozent, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere und ähm ich,
hoffe, dass wir so eine Diskussion hier nicht ähm auch nochmal führen müssen, auch wenn ihr natürlich versucht wird, von verschiedenen Stellen aufzubringen.
Deshalb gibt's natürlich auch hier Probleme und äh teilweise da kann man jetzt auch mal den Bogen hier an unsere Dauerthemen machen, ne? So Sachen wie Leistungsschutzrecht oder eben auch,
dieses dieser unsägliche Druck von Springer und anderen Verlagen
den öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk, das publizieren im Netz zu unterbinden, ne? So, Tagesschau-App hatten wir hier so als Thema generell äh die Problematik des Löschens. Ja, also diese Lösch,
da entwickelt sich nun langsam äh etwas Widerstand, wie ich jüngst meine Gefühl zu haben so, das könnte jetzt demnächst mal wieder auf der Agenda landen äh,
Selbstverständlich muss ein ähm öffentlicher Rundfunk diese Freiheit haben, denn deswegen haben wir ihn,
ehrlich gesagt die Probleme, die jetzt irgendwelche Verlage mit Monetarisierung haben, sorry
Aber das ist, das steht so hinten an und äh Facet, das ist halt einfach euer Markt,
Überlegt euch, wo ihr da was einbringen könnt. Sucht euch äh Felder aus, die äh ihr effizient bespielen könnt, aber.
Öffentlichen Rundfunk oder sagen wir mal einen unabhängigen Journalismus und zwar ein weitgehend unabhängigen Journalismus. Zu Opfern,
für irgendwelche Geschäftsfelder, nur weil ihr das für besonders lukrativ haltet oder gerne noch etwas lukrativer äh hättet, als es ohnehin schon ist.
Da gehe ich nicht mit,
Das äh das ist für mich einfach der falsche Ansatz und ich finde man muss den Spieß hier eher umdrehen und sagen was berechtigt euch hier eigentlich auch nur äh diesen Punkt
vorzubringen. Selbstverständlich brauchen wir ein möglichst transparentes Archiv all dieser
ganzen Beiträge und Konkurrenz im Internet, sorry, das ist halt auch ein Feld, das das gehört euch nicht
Ja, also das Internet ist für alle da. Es handelt sich hier einfach um das Universalausstrahlungsmedium für alles. Und selbstverständlich muss der öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk da sein. Und selbstverständlich muss er das auch,
einer für das internet angemessenen Form machen. Früher war halt das für die existierenden Medien an dem Verhältnis eine Form war halt Radio, dann Fernsehen,
so und in gewisser Hinsicht hätte ich auch mit einem öffentlich-rechtlichen äh Zeitungsprodukt eigentlich auch nicht unbedingt ein Problem, warum es so etwas so nie gegeben hat.
Man vielleicht auch nochmal diskutieren. Trotz alledem ist natürlich die Entwicklung, dass man jetzt auch mit Blog oder Textbeiträgen äh oder zumindest eben auch äh Audiovisuellen
äh Beiträgen begleiten, den Textmaterial. Finde ich gibt's überhaupt gar keinen Grund, dass in irgendeiner Form einzuschreiten äh einzuschränken. Und äh ich finde es gut und gerade im Internet, gerade in unserer,
mit so bekloppten Diskussionen wie Fake News et cetera durchzogenen Zeit sehr sehr sehr wichtig hier Portale zu haben, die eben nicht auf E
Klicks angewiesen sind und äh AdBlocker, Wars mit uns äh führen, sondern die halt einfach äh berichten, das tun, machen und so weiter. Und wenn andere Verlage der Meinung sind, sie können das besser und haben da bessere Rechercheteams und können sich da äh entsprechend positionieren
super, mach das, ja, dann sollt ihr auch da ähm euren Einfluss gewinnen und halten, aber eben nicht auf Kosten,
eines öffentlichen Rundfunks.
Vielleicht noch ganz kurz, weil du das mit dem mit der Löschpflicht der Depublikationspflicht gerade erwähnt hast. Ähm wir haben das hier, glaube ich, immer mal wieder besprochen, aber das ist inzwischen auch schon wieder so lange her, dass ich das nochmal ganz kurz historisch wiederhole. Und zwar.
Ist die Argumentation gegen die Onlineangebote der öffentlich rechtlichen TV-Sender immer wieder, dass diese
sich in den Bereich der Verlage bewegen. Und da gab es äh eine Beschwerde des Verbandes privater Rundfunk und
Telemedien bei der EU-Kommission, die sagte, dass die deutsche Rundfunkgebühr eine staatliche Beihilfe.
Zu sei, die wettbewerbsverzerrend gegen Verlage und Privatunternehmen wirken würde, da,
aber äh deshalb nicht okay sei, weil die Rundfunkanstalten einen eng begrenzten Funktionsauftrag haben. Nämlich Rundfunk. Und dann haben die argumentiert, na ja, dann macht euren Rundfunk, aber wenn ihr alle eure Sendungen auf Dauer.
Online stellt und äh für immer archiviert,
dann seid ihr nicht dann ist das nicht mehr Rundfunk, sondern dann ist das Telemedien ähm
oder quasi Verlagswesen und das können wir nicht und deswegen dürft ihr das dürft ihr dafür kein Geld ausgeben und dann wurde in Deutschland,
ähm zweitausend äh neun oder so, dann der ähm den Rundfunk,
Medien, Staatsvertrag oder sowas äh äh entschieden, Rundfunk, Änderungsstaatsvertrag äh entschieden, in dem gesagt wurde, okay, das muss alles wieder deplituliziert werden,
Der Witz ist, dass das natürlich ein Mordsaufwand ist, äh diese Sachen überhaupt wieder online äh offline zu nehmen, das teurer, die offline zu nehmen, als die online zu lassen.
Aber es ist halt gerade Recht und Gesetz und ähm schlecht. Es gab dann auch mal eine Webseite Depot Punkt org,
die hatten dann alle Sachen online gestellt mit Torentlinks und so.
Mhm.
Ich weiß gar nicht was da noch draus geworden ist, aber damals haben wir bei Netzpolitik Ork da drüber berichtet, dass wir irgendwie zweitausendzehn oder so, ich gucke, ob's das noch gibt.
Seite existiert noch, sieht aber irgendwie nicht so aus, als wäre die noch funktional.
Die ist Depop ist depabliziert.
Ja
Aber genau, da wird gekämpft und wir haben hier auch immer Behandlung oder öfter behandelt die Streitereien der Verlage gegen die Tagesschau-App.
Und unter anderem die dafür der Grund ist, dass in den auf den Tagesschauwebseiten so oft drunter steht unter den Artikeln über dieses Thema berichtete, was weiß ich, die Hessenschau
oder die Tagesschau am so und so viel in, dass es, damit sie rechtlich argumentieren können, dass das zusätzliche Inhalte zu ihrem Rundfunk,
Thematiken sind,
und nicht etwa ein Journalist ein unzulässiges journalistisches Angebot. Also das ist schon sehr äh schmerzhaft zu sehen, wer diese privaten äh Medienunternehmen,
dann da auch noch wirklich gegen unseren wirklich schön unsere wirklich schöne Idee des öffentlich finanzierten,
unabhängigen Rundfunks oder von mir aus, wenn jetzt kommen sie, ist doch nicht unabhängig gut, dann wenigstens von anderen abhängigen Rundfunk, ja, als äh Gegengewicht
zu haben, äh das ist eher traurig. So, jetzt haben wir.
Nach einer dreiviertel Stunde unseren Prolog durch,
Irgendwie, ich weiß auch nicht, was los ist, aber irgendwie ähm es wird irgendwie immer mehr,
Wir müssen uns da mal echt was überlegen. So ähm.
Der Bundestag.
Der Bundestag hat äh wie sich aus der letzten Sendung ja entnehmen schon nehmen ließ äh noch weiter äh entfaltet
der Medienlandschaft. Du hattest ja schon diverse Ahnungen äh geäußert und äh jetzt wollen wir nochmal gucken, wie das so ausgegangen ist.
Genau. Also der der Hintergrund, warum ich in der letzten Sendung Ahnungen geäußert habe ist, dass äh natürlich der eine oder andere,
Journalist oder Journalistin mal mich dann auch zu einer Einschätzung zu bestimmten Hergängen gefragt hat, die eben zu dem Zeitpunkt noch nicht,
öffentlich
behandelt wurden. Deswegen habe ich da so vorgedeutet, dass ich gesagt wird, da wird sich, aber der eine oder andere vielleicht noch wundern mit einer, mit einer Angriffsstory nach vorne geprescht zu sein, die,
unter Umständen sich nachher als Spekulativ ähm herausstellt. Also es sieht.
Im Moment so aus. Ähm dass bei dem Angriff eine Rolle gespielt hat, die Lernplattform,
Elias der Hochschule des Bundes.
Und diese diese Webseite äh wird betrieben unter WWW Punkt Lernplattform Minus BAK OEV Punkt Bund Punkt DE. Und äh wenn man die Webseite besucht, steht da lieber Lerner,
Liebe Lerner. Kann man so stehen lassen war heute das äh Verwaltungsgerichtsurteil.
Liebe Lerner und Lernerinnen.
So, liebe Lernende gehört sich da natürlich.
Ja
Plattform Elias wird zurzeit ist zur Zeit nicht erreichbar. Sie wurde auf Empfehlung des BSI vorsorglich vom Netz genommen, danke für ihr Verständnis.
Das klingt nicht gut und ähm die Spatzen pfeifen es von den Dächern, dass die Elias eine Rolle gespielt hat im Rahmen des.
Bundeshex.
Genau.
Jetzt muss man sagen, da da bietet also die Hoch, diese Hochschulen des Bundes bieten da Weiterbildungsangebote an.
Und ähm es sieht wohl danach aus, dass sie dort die Lernplattform Elias in der Version fünf Punkt eins Punkt sechs betrieben haben.
Welche Surprise Surprise nicht die allerneuste ist.
Zu nicht die allerneuste zu dem Zeitpunkt ein Jahr alt mit äh mehreren bekannten Wein Rebilitys, Hanno Böck ähm,
Und Haucke Giro haben die auf Golem mal rausgesucht. Äh zwei äh Cross Side Scripting, Schwachstellen, also wo man ähm.
Quasi,
Wenn man einen mit einem präparierten Link Nutzer oder mit einem präparierten Inhalt Besucher der Seite äh unter bestimmten Bedingungen dafür sorgen kann, dass denen etwas anderes angezeigt wird, was man in der Regel durch ein JavaSkrip mehr oder weniger frei bestimmen kann.
Äh Fehler bei der Mailzustellung, die irgendwie dazu geführt haben, dass bestimmte E-Mails bei den falschen Leuten gelandet sind ähm und
ein Nicht-Näher erläuterten Bug im Handling von Mediendateien. Das könnte also wenn er nicht näher erläutert ist könnte das natürlich einer der Fälle gewesen sein. Außerdem gab es eine,
ähm eine Schwachstelle in den Versionen vor fünf Punkt sechs Punkt eins.
Die das Platzieren abiträrer Dateien im Webrood ermöglicht hat. Da ist die Sache dann noch ein bisschen kritischer. Macht das so die das ist dann so eine Schwachstelle, mit der du.
Mit der Bad sozusagen erstmal was ablegt, was dann später dann vielleicht zum Einsatz kommt.
Ja, mit der du halt, was weiß ich, im besten Fall legst du da halt irgendwie dein PAP hin oder so und das macht dann, was du möchtest, ne? Also da ist dann, wenn du,
Dateien platzieren kannst, dann ist es sehr schlecht. Das war übrigens kleiner äh kleiner Referenz, äh auch eine der Schwachstellen, die den PC Wahl, die im PC Walhack eben das ausspielen der schädlichen Updates ermöglicht hätte. Ja, also solche Schwachstellen willst du wirklich nicht.
Ähm es sieht wohl so aus.
Und jetzt kommen wir zu dem zu dem von mir spekulierten Teil, wenn du so eine, wenn du jetzt so ein staatlicher Angreifer bist, dann.
Also das, was du letztes Mal spekuliert hast oder ist es jetzt immer noch spekulation.
Das ist jetzt Spekulation über dieses Elias-Ding.
Da würde ich jetzt mal, äh, weil also Hintergrund ist, ich wurde gefragt, boah, erklär mal bitte, wie sind die Angreifer denn darauf gekommen, wenn ihr Ziel das Auswärtige Amt ist, dass sie,
den Umweg über Elias gehen. Woher wussten die denn, dass in dem Elias das Auswärtige Amt offenbar auch Kurse besucht? Weil sie sind ja in der offenbar in der Lage gewesen über Elias oder über diesen.
Über das Eingehen, zumindest über den Vektor Elias am Ende siebzehn Rechner im Auswärtigen Amt,
zu kompromittieren. Ob die alle über Elias kompromitiert wurden oder in ist unklar, aber
Elias hat eine Rolle gespielt und da war die Frage na wie kommen denn diese Angreifer auf die Idee, wenn sie eigentlich das Auswärtige Amt angreifen wollen, dass sie ausgerechnet des Elias aufmachen? Woher wussten die denn, dass das Auswärtige Amt an dem Elias hängt.
Die Antwort darüber äh darauf ist natürlich die haben wahrscheinlich erstmal vor Jahren schon alles abgeklopft, was irgendwo unter Bund DE läuft,
und diese was alles an Subtomains existiert kannst du relativ schnell herausfinden,
wenn du dann das einfach dir einfach mal dein schönes Inventar anlegst und sagst das alles läuft unter unter Subdomains von Bund DE,
und dann da einfach regelmäßig mal vorbeischaust und feststellst, ach guck mal, das ist hier irgendwie so ein Open Sourcing. Das heißt, wir schauen uns da einfach mal die Liste der äh CVEs an, also der äh die Liste der öffentlich.
Bekannten Schwachstellen.
Kannten Schwachstellen oder wir wir werden die ein Update machen und da steht Security drin, dann schauen wir uns mal an, was da gefixt wurde und schauen mal, ob die das schon geändert haben
dann hast du so 'ne Plattform einfach in deinem in deinem Inventar und wenn da mal eine Schwachstelle drin ist, dann ohnst du die mal schnell nebenbei
minimalinvasiv und kümmerst dich erstmal nicht weiter drum, beziehungsweise machst aus deinem Angriff erstmal nicht viel und freust dich einfach nur, dass du einen Finger
ein Fuß in der Tür hast und wenn dann irgendwann Marschbefehl Berlin kommt,
auswärtiges Amt, dann hast du dich in deinen auf deinen Host schon umgeschaut und weißt, ach ja, hier guck mal in dem Elias, da sind doch diese AA-Leute, ähm, dann gucken wir doch mal, was die sich dafür Lerninhalte runterladen und dann schieben wir denen da vielleicht eine
Präparierte Datei mit rein oder nutzen die Mailerfunktion oder sonstiges
um unseren unseren Angriff auszuweiten. Und das ist etwas, was ich nicht müde werde zu betonen, wenn,
quasi der Befehl zur Informationsextraktion kommt,
Also zur zur Spionage oder der Befehl zur Sabotage. Das ist nicht der Moment, wo die äh Angreifer, dass das Keyboard,
zusammenbauen und anfangen zu hacken. Das ist der Moment, wo sie das, was sie vorher gemütlich alles unter ihr.
Unter ihre Fittiche bekommen haben, nutzen. Und das war auch das, was ich zum Thema äh Hacken, die jetzt die Wahl oder sonstiges äh immer gesagt habe, wenn sie es machen, dann sind sie auf jeden Fall längst drin,
Dann braucht man nicht zwei Monate vor der Wahl zu sagen, äh machen wir nochmal hier eine eine Firewall. Ja, das ist äh dann zu spät. Also so wird dieses Spiel nicht gespielt und so würde könnte ich mir,
Könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass sie in diesem Elias äh eben schon sehr, sehr viel länger drin gehangen haben,
Als sich der tatsächliche Angriff äh hier auf das Auswärtige Amt,
der ja auch mitläuft und womöglich schon seit über einem Jahr berichtet wurde, bevor sie den tatsächlich zur Ausführung gebracht haben.
Ansonsten Standardpasswörter werden da benutzt und so äh oder die Software,
zwingt die Leute nicht zum ändern des Standardpasswortes. Also da hätte es eine Reihe an Möglichkeiten gegeben.
Reinzukommen. Und so erstmal die Idee sich so ein unterferner liefen,
manifestiertes System zu suchen ist nicht.
Außergewöhnlich, sondern eher die naheliegende. Weil da guckt offenbar keiner gut hin,
dann schauen wir uns da mal um. Nehmen wir das erstmal hoch, gucken wir mal, machen nicht allzu viel Lärm, vielleicht kann man das später ja mal gebrauchen.
Ja und vor allem, wenn man jetzt mal die militärischen Analogien herbeizieht, so, also in dem Moment, wo ein Angriff rollt,
ist er auch schon mal geplant worden und da sind dann auch äh Truppen und äh so weiter in Stellung gebracht worden. Nachdem vorher was ausspioniert und äh na,
Wissen geschafft wurde, Intelligence nennt man das ja.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, in welcher LMP Folge das war, aber da habe ich mal davon berichtet, dass ich ja mal mit eine.
Sogenannten äh Cybermilitär mich unterhalten habe über seine Tätigkeit, der,
müssten wir nochmal raussuchen. Das war glaube ich auf jeden Fall sehr interessant, weil der mir relativ viel Einblick da reingegeben hat, dass sie selbstverständlich äh das Primärziel einfach erstmal war, überall einen Fuß in der Tür zu haben und dort nicht weiter aufzufallen,
unter anderem so Scherze gab, dass sie ähm die schlecht gesicherten Büchsen, dass sie das Problem hatten, dass,
andere so nicht staatliche Akteure
Also irgendwelche Cracker und Script Kiddies, die Dinger auch aufgemacht haben und dann da irgendwie, äh jo, hier Jolo, Fallsharing, ja, und dann viel zu laut waren und dann irgendwann die in die Kisten eigentlich gehört haben, aufmerksam gemacht haben auf diese Geräte.
Ähm was dazu führte, dass sie geputzt wurden und sie unter Umständen ihren Zugriff verloren,
habe ich damals erzählt. Was was bei ihm dazu geführt hat, dass er gesagt hat, die Büchsen, die wir geordnet haben, die haben wir als allererstes mal gepatcht, damit niemand anders auf dem Weg reinkommt, wie wir reingekommen sind.
Wir machen die nämlich sicher.
Kein, kein, kein Scheiß jetzt. Ähm der hatte in.
Also der hat gesagt, dass äh sage ich mal unter seiner Egide immer im Netz ein paar ungepatschte Büchsen waren,
er einfach nur einmal die Woche geguckt hat, ob die noch ungepatcht sind. In der Hoffnung oder in der Erwartung, dass jeder Angreifer, der was auf sich hält,
Äh die wenn er sie ohnt, nämlich sofort dicht macht. Das heißt, er hat tatsächlich als so quasi als Kanarienvögel äh irgendwo noch ein paar ungepatchte Systeme gehabt, um zu gucken, ob schon irgendjemand drin ist.
Also diese die Sendung suchen wir nochmal raus, müssen wir jetzt gar nicht weiter äh drauf eingehen. Ähm zweite interessante äh Meldung war.
Das Pfiff, die Spatzen auch schon länger von den Dächern. Ähm.
Wir haben ja in der letzten Sendung schon darüber gesprochen, dass der IVBB ja ein ein ausgesprochen sicheres Netz ist.
So sicher.
Also üblicherweise, wenn jemand sagt, das ist ein sicheres Netz, dann hast du äh.
Würdest du sowas sehen wie ähm du kommst eigentlich überhaupt nicht raus ans Internet? Außer ins Web,
und das auch nur durch einen Web Proxi,
ja? Das heißt, äh und dieser Webproxi äh wenn man das dann irgendwie nach, wie es heute so gerne als äh best Practice bezeichnet wird. Dieser Webroxi ähm macht dir dann noch die HTTPS-Verbindungen auf,
Das heißt auf allen Clients ist irgendwie eine CA installiert, die,
dem Betreiber gehört und der Proxi, der dazwischen ist, macht dir, macht dir jede SSL-Verbindung auf,
und stellt die nach außen wieder her, ja? Und äh man könnte sagen, da findet äh die eine wunderschöne Umschlüsselung statt,
Mit dem Ziel, dass eben auch Verschlüsselte, ausgehende Webverbindungen an zentraler Stelle äh gemonitort und entschlüsselt werden. Ja, damit will man ähm.
Verhindern, dass da irgendwie, ne? Traffic stattfinden kann, der nicht,
an zentraler Stelle kontrolliert wird und dann kann man eben schauen, wenn da irgendwie jemand versucht noch eine Verschlüsselung obendrauf zu machen oder so, dann kann man das sofort flaggen und als verdächtig. Bin der.
Das ist der eine Weg nach draußen oder.
Der einzige Weg nach draußen will man meinen. Das andere, was aber alle Leute in so einem, in so einem Netzwerk immer brauchen, ist Email,
so ähm und damit die ihre E-Mails verschicken können, brauchen die einen Mailserver,
Und ähm da machst du, machst du üblicherweise dann äh natürlich auch einen internen Mailserver. Also das heißt du Expost, einen Mailserver nochmal im Internetz,
und sagst, okay, hier redest du, wenn du jetzt Mails verschicken möchtest, dann redest du hier mit diesem Server, wir geben dir ein DNS-Eintrag, der ist nochmal im lokalen Netz.
Quasi so die hauseigene Poststelle.
Hauseigene Poststelle. So und da lässt du, was lässt du da laufen? Natürlich in der Regel äh so ein ähm Exchange-Server, beziehungsweise heute heißen die ja auch Outlook,
Also die Outlook-Server-Exchange-Servercode keiner aussprechen. Deswegen hat man da gesagt, indem wir die jetzt auch noch ähm beziehungsweise.
So, das heißt, du sitzt als Angreifer, hast jetzt ohne Büchs aufgemacht, das heißt, dein einer Weg nach draußen führt durch den Webroxi.
Der unter Umständen auch noch ein Passwort verlangt. Das heißt, wenn du Pech hast, kommst du da nicht ohne weiteres muss durch, sondern musst die erst aus dem äh aus dem Browser äh noch das Webroxy-Passwort klauen,
wenn da überhaupt ein Browser ist, bei dem du das klauen kannst, oh das hatten wir, glaube ich, in der letzten Folge nochmal besprochen. Äh mitunter stehst du also recht doof da
um deine Kommunikation zu machen, denn du musst ja einerseits Befehle rauskriegen, äh äh Informationen raustragen,
und auch irgendwie dir Befehle reinholen,
Also was willst, was musst du machen? Also den Command and Control Kanal. Und da gibt's aber natürlich immer noch verschiedene Wege, wie du das machst.
Beliebt, DNS-Tunneling.
Also du du versteckst deine Kommunikation in die NS-Anfragen nach Subdomains, für die du den.
DNS-Server kontrollierst, das heißt, du sagst im Prinzip so, gib mal den.
An die Fragen.
Genau, du fragst, also du du kontrollierst in im Prinzip eine Domain.
Atomkrieg Punkt Meterebene Punkt ME.
Nee, du würdest, nee, du würdest einfach nur Meterebene ME kontrollieren, ja?
Und fragst, ob da Atomkrieg zu haben ist.
Und dann fragte einen deine Clients, fragen immer für Subtomains, sagen wir mal, Textrakers an, weil Textreckers relativ lang sein können.
Also Einträgedienstringen zurückliefern.
Genau, jetzt legst du darüber, machst du aber noch eine kleine SA Verschlüsselung, das heißt deine Clients fragen eigentlich immer verschlüsselte lange Subdomains an.
Und dein dein DNS-Server kann diese Subdomain Anfrage entschlüsseln, weiß was da gerade für eine Information kam und weiß, wie er darauf antworten muss. Das heißt, in dem Protokoll DNS, was eigentlich nur sagt, gib mir doch mal bitte den Record so und so,
kannst du jetzt abitäre Informationen austauschen.
Und das elegante ist, dass kannst du tun, obwohl du keine direkte Verbindung hast, denn wenn dein Client die DNS-Anfrage an seinen DNS-Server stellt und der DNS-Server die Antwort nicht weiß, dann fragt er.
Deinen.
Übergeordne.
Weil der derjenige ist, der diese DNS äh äh Domain quasi dafür Autor Autoritative Antworten geben kann. Das heißt, du hast ein Tunnelprotokoll durch DNS.
Was sehr schön ist, haben sie aber hier nicht gemacht. Ich wollte nur sagen, dass egal sobald du irgendwo die Möglichkeit hast, mit draußen Informationen auszutauschen, kannst du die immer umformen in einen Datenkanal. Ähm,
Hier haben sie sich entschieden, November Outlook haben. Dann nehmen wir doch Outlook,
und haben ihr Command and Control über äh E-Mail geregelt. Warum auch nicht? Das heißt, die Cliants haben ganz einfach äh E-Mails.
Gesendet und empfangen, beziehungsweise das ist jetzt noch unklar, ähm aus dem Bericht, den hier der von,
Äh warte mal ganz kurz von Hakan Tandri Verdi und ich weiß nicht genau, wer der zweite Autor war. Äh müsste ich nochmal kurz schauen.
Aber also süddeutsche Zeitung hat das hier erklärt. Ähm ja nur Hakan Tandriver, die einzige Autor. Ähm der also sagte.
Also aus dem Bericht geht nicht ganz klar hervor, ob sie auch ihre Antworten per E-Mail äh gesendet haben oder nicht. Aber was nämlich sehr schön ist,
du müsstest ja eigentlich dafür das E-Mail-Passwort haben. Jetzt hat aber Outlook den die Eigenart, das Outlook-Anhänge auf jeden Fall,
herunterlädt, auch ohne dass der Nutzer damit interagiert. Das heißt, hier du schreibst eine E-Mail.
Mitten im Anhang und in dem Anhang hast du Stenographisch irgendwie einen Befehl an deine Myware.
Verstärkt. Jetzt kommt der Outlook Client und lädt den Anhang auf jeden Fall runter und da der dann deinem Nutzer gehört.
Kannst du diesen anderen noch einsehen. Und wenn du dann irgendwie noch quasi versteckte Informationen, also damit meint er, steganographisch.
In der Datei noch was anderes versteckt.
Also es steht ja nur grafisch, nicht zu vergessen, mit nie zu verwechseln, mit genographisch, hier ist gemeint. Eine versteckte Information, zum Beispiel in Bildern oder in beliebigen Dateien. Das heißt, man hat halt,
Den Anblick einer normalen Datei, die einen zweckerfüllt, PDF, was auch immer, aber in irgendeiner Form, so dass es nicht auffällt, sind bestimmte Bits äh,
verändert oder Daten ergänzt, die sonst ignoriert werden und darin ist dann die eigentliche Information quasi versteckt.
Genau und kann, kannst du beliebig, einfach oder beliebig komplex machen ähm,
einfache, also in einem Word-Dokument, in einem PDF-Dokument, in all diesen Dateiformaten sind viele Dinge, die sind viele Felder möglich, die nicht Anzeige relevant sind.
Das heißt, du kannst da im Prinzip so viele Informationen mit rein.
Lasst uns wieder ein ein schönes
Bild dafür liefern. Ja, also wenn ich sozusagen einer großen Öffentlichkeit ein bestimmtes Ereignis mitteilen möchte ohne dass die anderen wissen, dass das ist, was macht man da? Man nimmt sich die größte Tageszeitung und schaltet einfach eine Anzeige mit,
irgendeinem würden äh Text, ja, machst du Anzeige. Hier gibt's Billiggummibärchen äh ab heute auch nicht in radioaktiv,
Und alle fragen sich nur so, hä aber für die anderen ist das halt so, dass Triggerwort und los geht's.
So genau kann man sich das.
Hast du an der eigentlichen Zeitung nichts ändern müssen sozusagen, hast einfach nur etwas genutzt, was sich einblenden lässt und fertig.
Genau und in diesem Fall hast du noch den Vorteil, dass die Zeitung automatisch runtergeladen wird, weil du sie im Perl
per E-Mail dahin geschickt hast. Ich bin mir nicht ganz äh im Klaren darüber, wie gut sie dann diese diesen Kommanden Control Traffic nachher wieder verstecken konnten und ob sie sich nicht doch auch der,
eines Interfaces bedient haben. Es ist auch nicht ganz klar, ob sie ähm ob sie,
das auch zur zur Exfiltration genutzt haben oder nur zum Empfang von Befehlen. Exfiltration steht hier unter Umständen ja auch einfach das Web wiederum zur Verfügung. Also,
Hier steht's einfach nur die Schadsoftware, die sich auf dem infizierten Rechner befindet, bleibt zunächst passiv. Sie scannt das Postfach und wartet auf Instruktionen
ne? Und das ist genau das, was du gerade machst. Die wartet einfach darauf, dass ihr irgendwann mal eine E-Mail an eingeht. Bestenfalls im Spamfolder landet. Aber der Anhang wird eben vielleicht doch mit runtergeladen und dann weiß sie, alles klar, da liegt irgendwo eine Datei und da musst du halt nur regelmäßig schauen
ob da eine Datei ankommt, die den Kriterien entspricht, unter denen dir eine Information hm mitgeteilt wird.
Klar, was sagt uns das jetzt? Also hier wurde auf jeden Fall rein
administrativ schon geschlurt, weil Software regelmäßig einsetzen in so einem sicherheitskritischen Bereich uns noch nicht mal schaffen nach einem Jahr wichtige Sicherheit Sicherheitsupdates einzuspielen
geht schon mal gar nicht. Wenn so.
Große Löcher auch noch drin sind mit äh man kann da beliebige Dateien reinplatzieren, wenn so ein Fehler,
Da gemeldet wird, wenn sowas ein Sicherheitslok ist, dann installiert man natürlich nicht nur die neue Software, sondern dann macht man alles platt. Weil dann weiß man,
nicht, ob das schon genutzt wurde und äh das ist auf jeden Fall der Trigger, der sagt, wir müssen den ganzen Scheiß neu aufsetzen. So. Oder wir setzen ihn halt schon überhaupt nicht mehr ein
nur da bei dem Punkt sind wir halt jetzt erst gekommen, ne? Gut, nachher weiß man immer alles besser, aber,
So Sicherheitsupdates einspielen, sorry, also das müsste jetzt irgendwie langsam mal durch sein, diese Information insbesondere äh in solchen Netzen.
Ja
Dazu sonst was sagen, also das ist doch alles mega naheliegend.
Ähm das mit dem also C und C über E-Mail siehste so oft nicht. Ähm aus dem und der Grund dafür ist eigentlich, dass du ähm.
Meistens auch noch andere Löcher gib.
Ja, du hast halt ein Jahr, du kommst woanders in der Regel leichter raus
Du hinterlässt ja Spuren auf den Mailservern, in den Logs und so weiter. Jetzt ist das wieder nicht schwer, weil du kannst immer von irgendeinem anonymen äh Remailer da mal schnell noch was hinschicken, was in der Inbox landet und so. Aber ähm.
Das äh findest du selten und ich wie gesagt, hier ist nicht ganz klar, ob sie darüber auch den Rückkanal gemacht haben oder ob sie da vielleicht einfach
auf Flicker ein Bild hochgeladen haben, würde ja auch reichen, wenn du dich wenn du eh schon stiganografie implementiert hast, dann letzte halt noch irgendwo, twitterst irgendwo ein Bild oder so, ne? Ähm.
Klassiker eben sich auch in in zu erwartendem und nicht verdächtigen Traffic zu verstecken.
Mhm. Dass du eben nicht.
Dass du eben nicht eine Verbindung zu irgendeinem komischen Command and Control Server in Russland aufbaust oder wo auch immer der steht, sondern du.
Veröffentlichst was in einem Social Network oder was auch immer, ne? Gibt genug Möglichkeiten, wie man,
unverdächtige Inhalte öffentlich zugänglich machen kann, die dann im Rahmen eines solchen Angriffs unter Umständen interessant äh werden. Aber sich als Hin und Rückkanal.
Ähm implementieren lassen, nutzen lassen,
zeigt aber auf jeden Fall, dass die Angreifer hier eine relativ klares, eine relativ klare Erwartung hatten, wo sie landen,
womit sie es zu tun haben werden, dass sie sich da wieder rausbohren müssen ähm und dass sie dafür eben offenbar eine schöne Kommunikationskanäle äh gebaut haben.
Ja. Wer lässt sich da erstmal nicht zu zu sagen, oder?
Ja und also genau, das das ist auf jeden Fall,
jetzt natürlich finde ich sehr interessant, wie sie damit umgegangen sind, also wie die Angreifer hier vorgegangen sind, zeugt auf jeden Fall so ein bisschen davon, ähm dass hier tatsächlich Leute am Werk waren, die.
Nicht zum ersten Mal machen, die da mit.
Die ihre Kreativität da schon ein bisschen gestellt haben. Ähm andererseits eben auch, was ich letzte Woche schon gesagt habe, es gibt keine sicheren Netze und wenn du.
Sobald du irgendeine Form von Kommunikation nach außen zulässt, dann wird dieser Kanal für Command Control genutzt werden und bitteschön.
Und ich sage doch mal, wer war's denn? Wer war's denn? Der Russe war's.
Na man, also zu dieser Zutur würde äh es passen, da so,
aber ich habe hier,
Ne, ich beziehe mich hier auf in sekundär Informationen aus dem Artikel, ich weiß nicht genau, wie da die Command and Control äh implementiert wurde, aber das, was da steht, klingt auf jeden Fall mal ganz pfiffig und ist nicht was von der Stange.
Gut. Dann gab's neue Minister.
Eine die lange Liste der GroKo äh,
Ministerposten war ja noch nicht vollständig. Die SPD ließ sich dann doch äh bitten und musste da wahrscheinlich noch den ein oder anderen Geschwistermord durchführen. Keine Ahnung, auf jeden Fall war es alles ziemlich
äh offen und
klappt dann wohl auch einige Überraschungen oder zumindest war nicht so ganz klar, was denn nun passieren würde, in dem so ein paar wenigen gesetzten Posten, also dass so Olaf Scholz jetzt äh auf den Finanzministerposten.
Ey, das ist doch so eine. Also wirklich, was? Der Mann ist doch auch eine wandelnde Katastrophe.
Na ja, also ich meine vielleicht ist Finanzministerium für ihn ganz okay, weil so als Innenminister hat er sich ja jetzt nicht unbedingt empfohlen.
Ne.
Also zumindest nicht für uns, ne? Wir erinnern uns oder Scholz war äh.
Ist ähm noch ein Ministerpräsident jetzt nicht mehr lange in Hamburg oder oberster Bürgermeister heißt das, also
ne, von der Funktion her vergleichbar Ministerpräsident des Namen und äh an der Stelle sei auch nochmal an unsere längere äh ausführlichere G zwanzig Sendungen
erinnert, wobei das wahrscheinlich überflüssig ist, weil die wurde so oft runtergeladen, dass ich mal vermute, dass alle die hier zuhören, da schon mal gehört haben, aber.
Demnächst in den Grundschulen als Allgemeinbildung übernommen. Anstelle von äh.
Was unsere Sendung.
Religions- und Sexualunterricht.
Schön wär's. Also wer vielleicht,
in der letzten Zeit neu dazu gestoßen ist und diese nun nicht gehört hat, mag da vielleicht unser Review nochmal äh begutachten. Ich denke, das war ein ganz signifikanter Beitrag zur Gesamtdebatte. Wie auch immer
Herr Scholz wird Finanzminister, was uns natürlich sehr viel mehr interessiert hat ist, wie geht denn das jetzt mit dem Justizministerium weiter, weil das war ja nicht ganz,
Entscheidend ähm im Bereich äh ne, allgemeiner Netzpolitik äh und,
wir können zumindest ähm schon mal sagen, Heiko Maas,
ist nicht mehr Justizminister, das ist schon mal ein Schritt nach vorne, weil ich denke, der hat sich äh aus unserer Perspektive nicht sonderlich mit Rom bekleckert, insbesondere wurde ja auch so seine die handwerkliche ähm.
Fähigkeit dieses Amt auszuüben ein wenig beklagt, also die zusammengekloppelten Gesetze waren einfach ja,
nicht waren fehlerhaft, sagen wir es mal.
Gesetze waren unsauber, das hat schlechte Arbeit, das das konnte man auf handwerklicher Ebene kritisieren,
inhaltlich ohnehin ähm dann noch diese äh,
zuletzt ist wie wie wir da auch aus manövriert wurden oder wie die Zivilgesellschaft ausmanöviert wurde. Beim Staatstrojaner, ne? Ich erinnere daran, wo ich irgendwie,
zwei Tage vor der Anhörung die Einladung bekomme ähm Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz, wo der neue Gesetzesentwurf irgendwie.
'ne Stunde veröffentlicht wird bevor die Sachverständigen,
Im Ausschuss sitzen und dazu Stellung nehmen, damit man dann sagen kann, ja die haben ja sich aber auf den alten äh hier bezogen, ne? Ist ja alles schon gar nicht mehr aktuell. Also das war eine, das war nicht mehr durch Nachlässigkeit, sondern das.
So Methoden, wie wir sie gerade in den USA beklagen, ja? So wie die Republikaner das im Kongress machen.
Das war ein, das war lieber Martin Schulz ein Angriff auf die Demokratie. Aber der Ausspruch mit der Angriff auf Demo,
Also Heiko Maas äh wirklich nicht also inhaltlich kann man ja immer äh unterschiedlicher Meinung sein, aber er hat wenigstens er noch nicht mal für seine Meinung ordentliche Arbeit geleistet.
Auf jeden Fall stellte ich fest, Linus, du bist ja nicht ohne Hoffnung, ne? Ich bin nicht ohne. Ja, weil.
Ich bin nicht ohne Hoffnung. Wie kommst du auf die Idee.
Bist nicht ohne Hoffnung, weil du hast ja in den in den äh Sendungsnotizen noch irgendwie verzeichnet einen Artikel, der darüber spekulierte, ob denn nicht der Partei linke Matthias Miersch künftig des Justizministerium führen dürfte,
der unter anderem dadurch aufgefallen ist, dass er zweitausendfünfzehn unter anderem gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung gestimmt hat, als einer der wenigen
glaube ich nur zweiundvierzig äh insgesamt äh ich weiß nicht aus zweiundvierzig der SPD oder zweiundvierzig der Koalition. Haben überhaupt noch so viele Sitze? Egal
Nun, wir müssen uns nicht darüber groß unterhalten, ob Herr Mirsch in seiner Rolle als Justizminister
dann auch irgendwie dem Unfallerprinzip der SPD gefolgt wäre, um dann künftig dann andere Haltungen einzunehmen, denn er ist es gar nicht erst geworden, tatsächlich Nachfolgerin von
Heiko Maas wird Katharina Bali, der hat natürlich für die VDS gestimmt, von daher alles prima und äh na, die GroKo kann hier,
Kontinuität wahren. Ähm ja, so bleibt dann nur unsere schon eingangs erwähnte äh Dorothee Bär,
Oder die einzige Ministerrang, die offenbar gegen die VDS gestimmt hat, inwiefern sie sich da mit ihrem Staatsminister Posten äh irgendwie durchsetzen können. Wissen wir nicht, aber glaube, wir können da äh brauchen da jetzt nicht viele Hoffnungen zu haben.
Ansonsten um's vielleicht mal komplett genannt zu haben, Hubertus Heil wird das Arbeitsministerium übernehmen, Svenja Schulze hab ich keine Kenntnis, wo die jetzt gerade herkommt, das Umweltministerium und Franziska Giffey
in Berlin relativ bekannt geworden als Bürgermeisterin von Neukölln, die Wesentlichen die,
Politik ihres Vorgängers äh fortgesetzt hat, wurde nicht ganz unerfolgreich, in dem doch krisengeschüttelten äh.
Nicht dieser Buschkowski, diese Politik hat die fortgesetzt.
Ja schon, ne, ist halt so dieses äh auf der einen Seite ne harte Hand, also schon gegen,
Kriminalität vorzugehen, aber auf der anderen Seite. Und das ist ja durchaus ein erfolgreiches Modell, muss man sagen, auch auf wenn man das europäisch vergleicht äh sozusagen aber auch dann eben Integrationsangebote äh zu machen,
zu sagen, ne? Hand ausstrecken und aber auch mal zuschlagen,
Ich habe nicht zu viel Einblick äh äh in das, was sie getan hat und wofür sie äh steht, aber sie hat relativ schnell äh da einen Eindruck hinterlassen und das hat jetzt eben dazu geführt, dass sie dann,
nach oben befördert wurde und jetzt schauen wir mal, was sie da auf dem Familienposten ausrichten kann. Für unsere Perspektive, unsere netzpolitische,
politische Perspektive sind natürlich die Nicht-SPD,
Ämter, äh, Ministerämter viel interessanter, das haben wir ja hier eingehend schon äh beleuchtet, eben mit der einzigen Ausnahme des Justizministeriums und da werden wir jetzt mal schauen, was die Frau Barley so äh auf dem Tisch äh zu legen hat.
Gespannt.
Haben wir denn jetzt auch schon gesagt, was äh Heiko Maas als Strafe bekommen hat?
Na ja, der der darf jetzt ein Ministerium führen, wo keine Gesetze ausgearbeitet werden.
Das ist, das ist das einzig Gute, das ist das einzig Gute, aber er hat die im Prinzip als.
Haben die Zweitprestige trächtigste Position inne. Lymphdi des Außenministers.
Ja. Man wird halt so lange befördert, bis man nichts mehr.
Das heißt als nächstes wird der äh Bundeskanzler.
Ja, wie wird's denn jetzt noch loswerden.
SPD.
Ja, wie, genau, wie wird's denn sonst noch loswerden? Ja, oder schickst den zu Gasproben. Aber also es ist, ich muss es wirklich bemängeln.
Weil ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das ist, dass die SPD weiter in Re.
Also Heiko Maas ganz ehrlich, ich habe da ähm in letzter Zeit beschäftigt mich das. Ähm.
Wir haben offenbar.
Kein oder so gut wie kein seriöses Personal mehr. Um damit irgendwie da oben diese Politik zu bestücken. Und einer der Gründe dafür ist, dass.
Menschen, die versagen zur Belohnung.
Nach oben befördert werden, statt sie wieder in das Loch zu schicken, aus dem man sie irgendwann mal rausgeholt hat. Und es geht nicht an, Leute, die eine ähm sage ich mal, eine eine lange Spur.
Verbrannte Erde hinter sich führen ähm aus Mitleid oder was dann einfach zu befördern. Also Olaf Scholz
sorry, hat den hat den Lachtest und die Feuerprobe nicht bestanden. Äh Heiko Maas hat jetzt genug Schaden angerichtet
man kann natürlich argumentieren ja im im als Außenminister verwurstet der wenigstens nicht mehr die Innenpolitik. Ja schön, gut,
aber ich halte das nicht für äh für ein akzeptables System. Da muss man sich ernsthaft Gedanken drüber machen. Und das ist nicht nur in der Politik so, es wird ja auch in der Wirtschaft regelmäßig bemängelt, dass du das am Ende.
Die weniger Kompetenten Personen ähm befördert werden in Führungspositionen kommen während äh kompetente Personen aufgrund ihres Sachverstandes an den Stellen,
bleiben, wo man sie tatsächlich braucht, nämlich da, weil sie die Arbeit machen. Ich prangere das an.
Ja, Prager du, wir nehmen das jetzt erstmal so wie's kommt. Und wir können es ja dann so äußern, wenn konkrete Maßnahmen.
Der einzige Vorteil ist, so ein, so ein Außenminister hat viel Reisetätigkeit. Das heißt, wenn wir Glück haben, sind wir einen größeren Teil der Zeit los. Also man muss auch immer was Positives sehen.
Also ich würde ja jetzt nicht sagen, dass das Außenministerium komplett aus den Augen, aus dem Sinn bedeutet, weil an der an der Front wird
eigentlich noch sehr viel mehr bestimmt, wohin's so mit Deutschland geht und ähm
Ich will ihm gar nichts Negatives unterstellen. Vielleicht ist das ja sein Ding. Ja, jetzt muss er zumindest keine Gesetze mehr schreiben
Sigmar Gabriel war ja ganz zufrieden mit seinem Nachfolger, aber wahrscheinlich ist ihm zu dem Zeitpunkt auch schon verboten worden, weiterhin noch irgendwas Doofes über
SPD Mitglieder zu sagen, sonst gibt's noch mehr auf die Fresse. Ähm Idono, keine Ahnung
Also die SPD könnte sich jetzt mal wieder dran machen, mal sich mal wieder ein Image zu erarbeiten, aber sorry, die Performance der letzten Monate.
Ein Wunsch hätte ich ein, einen Wunsch hätte ich an unseren neuen Außenminister, ähm so die die ganzen ähm
Also Meinungsfreiheit ist ja sehr wichtig und ähm wenn man sich überlegt, wie die in China oder in Russland
so stark unter die Räder kommt, ne? Da könnte doch unser Außenminister mal ein starkes Zeichen setzen und hier äh die Demokratie
und die Meinungsfreiheit hochhalten. Da hat er ja als,
Gründervater des Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetzes bestimmt den ein oder anderen Lacher auf seiner Seite, wenn er sich demnächst gegen für Menschenrechtsfall gegen Menschenrechtsverletzungen in Russland einsetzen möchte oder so.
Gut. Kommen wir zu unserem Lieblingsthema der letzten Wochen.
Nee, das ist ein neues Thema. Wir haben bisher immer nur den mangelnden Infrastrukturausbau bemängelt.
Wir haben bisher noch nie wir haben noch nie hier über den Infrastrukturrückbau gesprochen.
Das war auf jeden Fall äh ein.
Eine Meldung, die ist in sich äh hatte, das ging dann auf Twitter rum, dass Leute in Niedersachsen
Brief bekommen haben von der Titelkom, wo sie teilweise schon seit vielen, vielen Jahren
Kunde waren und sich zumindest glücklich schätzen durften, ein fünfzig Megabit Downloadlink zu haben. Ich finde das immer so ein bisschen doof, wenn man von fünfzig Megabit Internetanschlüssen redet, weil,
Sind ja gar keine, ja? Also eigentlich müsste man,
ähm eigentlich müsste man fairerweise immer so diese diese Uploadgeschwindigkeit dann noch mit irgendwie einrechnen. Also irgendwie so.
Aber lassen wir das.
VDSL zwei, was halt fünfzig Megabit bringt, das ist so das, was äh die deutsche Bundesregierung als Ziel ausgegeben hat, irgendwann mal zweitausendfünfundzwanzig allen dann nochmal anbieten zu können,
Leute die äh jetzt hier betroffen waren, hielten ein,
Brief von der Telekom, denen ihnen angekündigt wird. Sie müssten die Technik jetzt rückbauen und könnten ihnen künftig nur noch sechzehn Megabitter anbieten,
Also den Tag für dich hätte ich erleben irgendwie meine, da bist du,
so das Gefühl so, oh Mann, ich immerhin, ja, es mag ja alles schlimm sein, aber immerhin habe ich fünfzig Megamit. So und dann kriegst du irgendwie so einen Brief, so. Guten Tag, sie hatten sie interessierten sich doch auch äh,
Sie interessierten sich doch auch für Mittelalterfeste, wie wär's mit dem passenden Internetanschluss dazu.
Das ist also das ist echt krass, weil also ich meine, was,
die Königin dir dann. Also das ist so die eine Sache, die für mich nie in Frage kommt, ja. Oder äh also auch wo ich nie von ausgegangen bin, dass wenn also wenn du
dich zum Beispiel für Wohnungsmiete oder Wohnungs äh äh Kauf oder irgendwas interessierst, dann steht bei Spiegel nicht Spiegel,
Hausbau vierundzwanzig oder wie, ne? Ähm steht hier unten nochmal. Der DSF Verfügbarkeit prüfen, ne? Das ist ja einer der wichtigsten Faktoren beim,
bei der, bei der Suche einer Wohnung gibt es da DSL und dann.
Grundstück oder was auch immer, ja. Hm.
Und dann guckst du da und da steht der VDSL und da wird.
Ein Haus gebaut.
Muten so, du würdest niemals einpreisen, das zittert ja auch wieder weggenommen werden kann.
Das ist auch wirklich geil.
Also das ist äh.
Na ja, jetzt war natürlich die Frage,
Wie konnte es dazu kommen? Der äh Kunde äh beklagte sich dann auf äh Twitter, unter anderem griff dann auch Telekom hilft irgendwie ein und meinte so, na ja
Sie werden ja dazu gezwungen, regulatorisch Bundesnetzagentur wäre ja Schuld und sie könnten da ja überhaupt nichts machen. Stellt sich raus,
alles gar nicht, die Bundesnetzagentur hat dann irgendwie gleich auch auf Twitter mal reingrätscht und einen interessanten, aufschließreichen Brief veröffentlicht,
aus dem relativ klar hervorgeht, dass äh die Änderungen in den Regulatorien mitnichten, einen Rückbau nahelegen, sondern ganz im Gegenteil, dass sie das,
die etwas kompliziert formulierte Texte da, die ich jetzt im Einzelnen so nicht wiedergeben kann und will. Das sei ja sozusagen auch,
Wäre ja sozusagen auch äh unmöglich, dass ein ein Rückbau äh stattfinden kann, also dass man sozusagen danach mit weniger da steht, als man vorher hätte.
Womit die Telekom so ein bisschen frei rumhing. Stellt sich natürlich die Frage, was war denn jetzt hier eigentlich passiert.
Also der Brief lautet äh sehr äh geehrte Kundin. Na ja, sehr geehrter Kunde. Wir bauen das Thema Kommunikationsnetz der Zukunft und eröffnen unseren Kunden immer neue Möglichkeiten. Und du denkst so, oh ja geil, jetzt geht's.
Doch leider gibt es einige wenige Gebiete, in denen der Netzausbau durch die Telekom nicht möglich ist. Wir können deshalb auch bereits bestehende VDS äh Angebote nicht mehr aufrechterhalten,
Das betrifft auch ihren Anschluss. Sie wohnen in einem Gebiet, in dem wir unser Netz derzeit nicht für hohe Bandbreiten ausbauen können. An ihrem Wohnort muss die Telekom ihre bestehende VDSL-Technik entfernen. Boah!
Die gelben Bulldozer vor dem Haus stehen und so.
Da steht die Dorffeuerwehr mit einer Kasten Bier und so ein Brett mit dem Nagel durch und steht am Dieslem und sagt so Junge.
Ja mit dem Räuter.
Boah, das ist so, das ist so geschmacklos, das ist so ekelig.
Ja. Also da du das jetzt hier so ausführlich vorliest und wahrscheinlich jetzt eh schon vorbei ist mit einer kurzen Sendung,
Also was die Bundesnetzagentur dann als Infomimo.
Groß bringt hier Bundesnetzagentur hat durch die Ausgestaltung der regulatorischen Rahmenbedingungen für den Victoringausbau im HVT Nahbereich sichergestellt, dass jedem Unternehmen und so auch der Telekom im Falle eines Victoringausbaus durch ein anderes Unternehmen ein Angebot mit,
hochbitratigen VDSL zwei und VDSL zwei Vectoring Produkten weiterhin möglich bleibt,
Dabei war und ist es ein Anliegen der Bundesnetzagentur, dass es für die Endkunden zu keiner Verschlechterung der eigenen Versorgung kommt, sondern ihnen eine breite Auswahl zwischen den Angeboten verschiedener Produkte und Unternehmen,
erhalten bleibt. Man ahnt schon, der Tick, es geht noch ein bisschen weiter, aber vielleicht um mal auf den Punkt zu kommen,
Hintergrund für diese ganze Geschichte ist ein Streit zwischen dem Oldenburger äh Energieversorger EWE und der Telekom,
die sich unter anderem auch letztes Jahr noch auf eine Aufteilung gegenseitige Nutzung ihrer Glasfasernetze äh geeinigt hatten, die also quasi in diesem Segment in äh Niedersachsen ähm.
Vielleicht gemeinsam aufgestellt sind, aber zumindest sozusagen eine eine Kooperationsvertrag hatten und aus Gründen,
die mir jetzt nicht so ganz äh klar sind, beziehungsweise die ich jetzt nicht so habe, recherchieren können, handelt es sich jetzt hier bei diesem besagten,
Gebiet, diesem Versorgungsgebiet um eines, wo jetzt ab August
EWE quasi die Hoheit hat. Das heißt, die sorgt für die eigentlichen Glasfaserausbau und damit eben auch für den Betrieb dieser Last Mile und dieser grauen Boxen, in der man dann eben auch Vectoring anbieten könnte.
Weil das ist ja sozusagen dieses bisherige Ziel gewesen. Ja, Glasfaser schon, aber nur auf der Straße und dann endet das äh versagt das halt in diesen Kästen. Äh ich vergesse immer das passende Fibertus äh Buchstabe Ding dafür.
Bitte.
FireTodics, dann.
Nee, heißt es nicht Körb oder.
Ja ähm
Auf jeden Fall landet das in diesem Kasten und ab da werden dann halt die guten alten Kupferkabel aus Kaisers Zeiten äh verwendet und irgendwie soweit vergewaltigt, dass man da maximale Geschwindigkeit rausholen kann, was eben noch rauszujucken ist. Und dieses Vectoring, was ja hier auch schon öfter besp
und beklagt wurde, ist ja so 'ne Technik mit der man sozusagen um dieses,
nochmal melden möchte und ach gucke mal, jetzt kriegt man nochmal das Doppelte raus, das klingt ja so schnell äh
Problem ist nur, dass du dann in dem Moment, wo du das machst, da sind ganze,
trale Angebot dieser Kabel so nutzt, dass du dann eben auch wirklich für alle Anschlüsse nur noch einen einzigen Betreiber haben kannst an dieser Box und das dann sozusagen Hoheit nicht von einem einzigen Anbieter macht, was natürlich ein bisschen Deliberalisierung widerspricht, dass man an der Stelle eben
Anschlüsse an beliebige Betreiber vermieten kann, aber dann brauchst du quasi so ein alles übergreifendes Gerät und
Das bedeutet wiederum, dass die Telekom, um dann dort Kunden zu halten und zu versorgen, sich mit diesem Betreiber über die Kosten äh einigen muss, so wie sich,
die meisten Anbieter übrigens in Deutschland halt über die Kosten dann eben mit der Telekom einigen müssen, weil die natürlich die meisten dieser Kisten betreibt. Und offensichtlich war das irgendwie ein Problem.
Also früher konnte, es konntest du zumindest theoretisch eine Kiste daneben stellen mit äh ähm diesem Vectoring geht das nicht mehr. Es muss eine Kiste alle Kupferkabel machen, ähm weil du das, weil du kopf.
Weil die Logik dann halt in diesem Kasten ist, also früher bei dem VDSL,
ging dann sozusagen die Leitung zum Hauptteilaposten und da hat sie dann eben einfach deine eigenen Batterien und dann konntest du das mit eigener Technik ansteuern und selber definieren, was da eben geht und nicht und wie das
konfigurierbar ist et cetera. Aber in dem Moment, wo du Vectoring machst, muss eben diese ganze Intelligenz, in dieser grauen Box sein und da können halt nicht fünf Anbieter nochmal ihre eigene Technik reinhängen und deswegen ist das sozusagen
nur
so zu machen und das ist halt auch ein Problem, das heißt Victoring, so erstrebenswert, ja, so eine Verdoppelung einer einer einer einer existierenden Leitung, also Verdoppelung der Kapazität einer existierenden Leitung sein mag
hatte einfach von vorne rein schon dieses Problem, dass man im Prinzip die angestrippte Liberalisierung an der Stelle schon wieder aufheb
Natürlich und das sagt jetzt auch die Businessnetzagentur müssen dann entsprechende virtuelle Angebote äh gemacht werden, ne? Weil letzten Endes ist
mir ja auch egal, wer da die Technik betreibt, Hauptsache die Daten kommen durch und es ist klar
mit wem ich den Vertrag aushandele und was die Kosten sind, nur muss natürlich dann in dem Moment sich auch irgendwie auch alle einig werden äh zu welchem Preis in dieser Zugang zu machen ist. Und der Max jetzt tausend Vorgaben geben mit, dass das ja im Rahmen zu sein hat und irgendwie
so weiter.
Vor allem ist das ja etwas, was die Telekom sehr gut kennt. Ja, also dieser Zusammenhang ist der Telefon der Telekom sehr gewiss, äh weil sie ja,
In dieser Situation gegenüber den meisten anderen Betreibern, in den meisten Fällen ist, dass diese nämlich ähm sich an ihre,
Verbindungen mit dran.
Mieten, ja? Wenn du jetzt irgendwie bei eins und eins ein Telefonanschluss ähm.
Bestellst, dann buchen die diesen Port bei der Deutschen Telekom und dann kommt der, schickt die deutsche Telekom jemanden um die Kabel da zu prüfen und dann hast du irgendwann,
Zahlt sie eine Rechnung an die an eins und eins und eins und eins zahlt irgendwas an die deutsche Telekom für die Nutzung der von der deutschen Telekom bereitgestellten letzten Meile.
Was dazu führt, dass die deutsche Telekom natürlich dadurch motiviert ist den angeblichen Preisanteil.
An ihren Preisen durch die letzte Meile enorm hoch zu halten, damit sie den möglichst den größten Teil ihrer angeblichen Kosten äh weitergeben kann an andere Betreiber, damit die nicht sinnvoll mit der deutschen Telekom konkurrieren können.
Das ist ja der der Kern der Angelegenheit.
Ich bereue es ein wenig mich in den neunziger Jahren über solche Begriffe wie Datenautobahn etwas lustig gemacht zu haben, weil Herr Kohl das ja so aufbrachte und wir alle herzlich lachten et cetera. Allerdings muss ich halt mittlerweile feststellen
da hätte man wahrscheinlich eigentlich mal eher aufspringen sollen auf den Zug, weil dieser Vergleich mit dem öffentlichen Straßennetz, der ist ja halt eigentlich ganz praktisch. Man stelle sich jetzt mal vor, dass in jedem Ort
jede jeder Zugang zum Haus, jede Straße mal von anderen Unternehmen gebaut wird,
die dann anderen, die dann darauf fahren wollen, dass dann sozusagen on Case bei Case Basis äh verkaufen wollen oder müssen,
Ja, also so permanente Straßen baut, würde nicht funktionieren. Und genauso wenig funktioniert es halt auch in Deutschland. Also,
Ist nicht der einzige Grund, aber ein Teil
Grund warum alles so schleppend läuft ist, dass ich viele Unternehmen hier auch einfach gegenseitig behaken. Und jeder der irgendwo mal so ein bisschen den Hut auf hat natürlich sofort alle anderen versucht kurz zu halten um dann einfach eigene vor
Teile zu haben. Und da das ist immer so eine Frage ist mit du kriegst überhaupt Zugang oder gar nicht
ja und dass hier kein äh wirklich offener Markt ist, in dem sich die Preise letzten Endes durch die Kunden getrieben ausgleichen können. Ähm.
Stecken wir an der Stelle halt auch fest. In dem Moment, wo diese Glasfaserstrecke, ja?
Und vielleicht eben auch wenn man tatsächlich irgendwo der Meinung ist, Vectoring betreiben zu müssen. Wenn das Ganze zum Beispiel der Bundesnetzagentur, beziehungsweise irgendeinem vielleicht noch zu gründenden Netzwerk
Betriebsgesellschaft im des öffentlichen Rechts unterliegen würde, ja? Die wo dann auch klar ist, wie das mit Investitionen ist, da kommen wir auch eh gleich nochmal drauf.
Dann äh sehe das halt ganz anders aus, weil natürlich klar wäre, dass ab ein solcher eine, dass eine solche Infrastruktur selbstverständlich allen
Betreibern des Marktes offen Zustände. Ja, also man hätte sozusagen nicht nur den einen oder den anderen Provider an der Stelle, sondern man hätte einfach,
eine Kiste in der Nähe des Hauses, wo man dann Kabel hin hat, im Idealfall natürlich Glasfaser, wo man sich dann einfach reinstöpselt mit seinem Laptop oder seinem,
Smartphone vielleicht auch und dann einfach auswählt. Ja. Welchen von diesen
Einhundertfünfzig Internetprovidern, die es in Deutschland so gibt, äh hätte ich denn jetzt gerne. So, wer hat denn das richtige Paket für mich? Und da ist das mit der Preisentwicklung natürlich
sofort eine ganz andere Nummer. Wir haben da schon öfter drüber gesprochen, Schweden auch in anderen Ländern gibt es solche Sachen, das ist kein,
Es ist jetzt keine Fantasie, keine keine Hackerfantasie, das ist einfach blanke Realität. Und wenn man sich halt anschaut, wie das mit dem Netzausbau in diesen Ländern vorangeht
möchte man einfach nur noch weinen, dass wir unter solchen Zuständen noch zu leiden haben. Kein Wunder, dass wir auf Platz fünfundzwanzig sind.
Ist bei Gas und Strom ja genauso und ähm.
Genau. Und gutes Beispiel.
Wunderschönes Beispiel. Hier, was hier geschehen ist und und,
Hier hat also jemand anders jetzt den Zuschlag bekommen, die Hauptverteiler zu betreiben und diese Ewe Tel GmbH ist verpflichtet der deutschen Telekom, genauso wie umgekehrt.
Zu angemessenen.
Angemessenen Preisen die Nutzung zu ermöglichen. Das heißt, was hier ganz einfach äh die Situation gewesen wäre. Wenn die Preise die Evitel verlangt, von der deutschen Telekom zu hoch wären.
Dann hätte die deutsche Telekom die ähm die Möglichkeit gehaben, äh die Möglichkeit gehabt, den angebotenen Produktproduktvertrag von der Bundesnetzagentur prüfen zu lassen.
Also.
Nunfalls Abmahn.
Angenommen das Evetel sagt, das ist Evetell sagt ja tausend tausend Mark,
Dann sagt die deutsche Telekom, nee, äh, zu viel, dann hätte die deutsche Telekom quasi sich an die Bundesnetzagentur wenden können und sagen können, bitte schlichten, das, was sie äh Evitel hier von uns verlangt, ist marktverzerrend bösartig.
Das ist sie doch nicht gewohnt, normalerweise beklagen sich doch immer die anderen über sie.
Und da haben sie genau, da haben sie drauf verzichtet, weil sie wissen, dass äh ähm weil sie bei ihrer Anwälte nur darin erfahren sind, solche Ansprüche abzuwehren, nicht solche Ansprüche zu stellen,
Ja und dann haben sie gesagt, alles klar, dann droppen wir es lieber ganz. Und ähm.
Das äh sagt ja hier die Deutsche die Bundesnetzagentur ganz klar. Im Ergebnis bedeutet dies das weder aus technischen noch aus regulatorischen Vorgaben folgt, dass ein Unternehmen, dem das Ausbaurecht für die betroffenen HVT-Nahbereiche nicht zugesprochen wurde
eigenen Endkunden ab August zwanzig achtzehn nur noch ein leistungsmäßig eingeschränktes Produkt Portfolio anbieten könnte.
Insbesondere folgt Heroes keine zwingende Beschränkung auf ADSL Produkte. Ähm und äh die
also sie sagen im Prinzip so ist eine reine Entscheidung dieses Unternehmens und straft dann hier dieses Social Media Team
der deutschen Telekom auch noch Lügen, die nämlich behaupten, wir tun das. Wir tun das sehr ungerne, aber wir müssen unsere Technik zurückbauen. Dies war eine Entscheidung der Bundesnetzagentur äh.
Feinerlicher Laden.
Alter. Und dann auch noch Lügen. Da komme ich nicht mit zurück und sag doch einfach. Ne, pass auf, wir haben uns überlegt, wir brauchen euch eigentlich gar nicht.
Und wir haben auf, wir haben ausgerechnet, dass ähm,
vielleicht dreißig Prozent der Leute äh sich kommentarlos einfach in beschisseneren Vertrag für fünf Prozent weniger Kosten überführen lassen und dann machen wir unterm Schnitt noch Plus. Und deswegen machen wir das,
Und alle anderen können ja jetzt zu Evitel gehen. Unglaublich.
Ja, aber die Nuss.
Wir haben jetzt eine neue Regierung, jetzt wird alles anders. Gibt nämlich jetzt einen neuen Kanzleramtschef Helge Braun von der CDU.
Ein verrückter Typ. Entschuldigung.
Die Kulturreferenz habe ich jetzt nicht verstanden.
Was du hast eine Fußballkulturreferenz nicht verstanden.
Nein.
Ist in Ordnung, mach weiter.
Okay. Auf jeden Fall äh Helge Braun hat sich geäußert zu den künftigen Förderungsmaßnahmen des Bundeskanzleramts,
denn die bisherigen waren nicht ganz so erfolgreich
Ähm hatten ja schon vorhin angesprochen, dieses Ziel von fünfzig Megabit äh Ev-Revere, was ja dann irgendwann mal, wenn wir alle in Rente sind, dann verwirklicht äh sein soll. Ähm,
Da wurde ja jüngst ein Topf aufgemacht von vierhundert Millionen Euro, Förder äh Sachen, Probleme mit solchen Fördertöpfen ist
dass ihr natürlich irgendwie immer relativ schwierig zur Anwendung zu bringen sind, weil dann muss es dann Ausschreibungen geben, europaweite Ausschreibung, Anträge, Pipapo, das Ganze muss dann genehmigt werden, dauert alles lange
Ergo sind von diesen vierhundert Millionen Euro nur geringfügig mehr als ein Prozent, nämlich fünf Millionen Euro überhaupt zum Einsatz gekommen,
dementsprechend war äh was so diese ganze Ausbauförderung betrifft
Ist da nicht viel passiert und wir wissen da auch äh ne, weil Kupfer ist ja Glasfaser, dass äh eben auch dieses Viktoring im Rahmen dieses Glasfaserausbaus äh davon profitiert hat.
Das haben wir nun schon oft genug beklagt. Jetzt herrscht eine neue Erkenntnis. Vermutlich, ich sage mal,
In den letzten Wochen ist es ja öfter rumgegangen, hab jetzt grade keine Links zur Hand, vielleicht können wir die auch nochmal raussuchen, aber es gibt ja schöne Aufstellungen, Statistiken,
Wo denn Deutschland so steht und stellte sich raus, aha im Glasfaserausbau sind wir irgendwo so unter Ferner liefen.
Ungefähr da, wo Linus und Tim immer gesagt haben. Unten.
Unten fünfundzwanzigster, sechsundzwanzigster Platz, hinter Rumänien und so, ja? Also das.
Wir hinfahren, wenn wir mal ein größeres Update downloaden müssen, dann fahren wir nach Ru.
Rupädien so. Ja, also links hast du noch so einen so einen Ochsenkarren äh Faden irgendwie über den Dörfer.
Ja, der hat aber schon, der hat aber schon GPS und LTE.
Ja, also also Lasten-Esel mit Glasfaseranschluss so, ja? Äh soweit sind wir noch nicht. Ah, es ist auch wirklich echt alles zu b.
So und jetzt aber Konsequenz daraus.
Ja, ganz konsequent äh daraus ist äh dass alles anders wird und man lässt das Kupfer dann nochmal raus und macht die Glasfaserförderung nur noch für Glasfaser,
Ja, toll. Super, gratuliere. Ähm.
Wir sind wie immer äh gespannt, ja, man möchte auch äh
diesen diese Förderkonstruktion wohl dahingehend äh ändern, da kenne ich mich jetzt ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so gut aus in diesem bürokratischen Zusammenhängen, aber es ist Problem mit diesen ganzen Ausschreibungen war wohl alles schwierig
einfacher soll es werden mit meinem speziellen Digitalisierungsfond auflegt und das nicht direkt an den Bundeshaushalt an
hängt, keine Ahnung, ob das dann irgendwie bürokratisch so ein Riesenunterschied
ausmacht, da wollen sie dann irgendwie auch die, die ganze Lizenzkohle, die sie demnächst erwarten für die Ausschreibung der Frequenzen, für fünf G Mobilfunk äh mit einfließen lassen und was sonst noch so bei UMTS noch äh,
übrig geblieben ist und äh jetzt ist halt davon die Rede nicht mit vierhundert Millionen Euro das Thema anzugehen, sondern so zehn bis zwölf Milliarden Euro an Start zu bringen.
Ja, das klingt natürlich jetzt schon mal nach viel, aber wenn man halt sieht, wie erfolgreich das gewesen ist, ähm kann man da glaube ich auch äh dem Ganzen mit einer gewissen Zurückhaltung begegnen. Die Frage ist natürlich vor allem
was soll's jetzt gesteckt werden? Wem soll's gegeben werden? Weil das Prinzip und das hatten wir ja nun gerade an diesem anderen Beispiel auch schön gesehen, dieses Prinzipunternehmen,
dabei finanziell zu unterstützen, ihren Ausbau voranzubringen. Er scheint mir halt nur so begrenzt, sinnvoll,
Würde man eben konsequent zum Beispiel dieses Geld in den Ausbau kommunaler Netze, also staatlich äh oder im im Besitz der Gemeinde befindliche Infrastruktur stecken und einfach sagen
Leute, wir bauen jetzt hier so lange
von allen gleichwertig nutzbare Infrastruktur aus, insbesondere in Bereichen, wo es derzeit noch gar keine gibt, aber auch nicht nur.
Ja? Und wir bauen jetzt einfach schrittweise ein System auf, was wir schon seit zehn Jahren hätten bauen sollen, aber leider aus irgendwelchen bekloppten politischen Gründen nicht gemacht haben, vor allem, weil wir überhaupt nicht verstanden haben, wovon wir reden. Ähm dann.
Würde man nämlich hier einen ganz anderen Druck erzeugen. Weil man nämlich auf, weil da Tür auf einmal alle Unternehmen sind, wir machen das jetzt selber. Oha.
So, dann, ne? Dann, dann, dann müssen die nämlich irgendwie schauen, wie sie damit klarkommen oder andererseits können sie auch sagen, ach na ja, Gott, ist ja vielleicht gar nicht so doof.
Dann haben wir die Scheiße vorm Tisch, dann können wir uns jetzt auf Werbung und äh Drosselungen und äh und Zero Rating konzentrieren. Und ja, ist doch super, machen wir. Jeder das, was er am besten kann.
Genau. Telekom kann weiter ihre bekloppten Angebote äh äh pflegen und,
Dann können sie ja sehen, wie sie damit äh überleben können. Also, auch hier gilt mal schauen. Wer offenbar nicht so viel Lust hat, zu mal schauen, ist äh.
Ralf Dummermuth, ich weiß nicht, ob das ein Name ist, den du auf dem Zeiger hattest, äh offenbar steckt der so in dieser Liste der reichsten Menschen dieser Welt äh in den Top dreihundert und hat da irgendwie.
Ja, aber Top dreihundert, das ist ja jetzt irgendwie da unten.
Wäre ja gut, aber es handelt äh immerhin.
Euch mir die Namen merken, ne? Also man ist ja gerne unter sich.
Nicht meine Liga.
Nachwuchs, die Nachwuchsförderung machen bei uns die Top zweihundert Milliardäre.
Na gut, aber Herr Dommermuth äh scheint zumindest soweit äh äh Checkungen zu haben. Er hat äh United Internet gegründet, ein Kondomerat, was sich über die Jahre aus der verschiedensten ISPs der ersten Stunde zusammen äh fusioniert hat.
Nicht XGMX oder sowas.
Da steckt so, ah ja, das, das steckt da mit drin, da ist aber noch einiges drin aufgegangen, äh verschiedene lokale Provider, wir hatten ja so.
Wer satt? Ja.
In den neunziger Jahren hatten wir ja noch sehr viele lokale Internetprovider, ne? Auch hier in Berlins NAFO, et cetera. Ich glaube, die sind auch äh alle in diesem äh Gebilde aufgegangen, auch wenn ich's ja jetzt gerade nicht so sicher sagen kann.
So und es ist nicht, es ist nicht äh GMX, es ist äh der Ursprung war eins und eins. Lese ich gerade,
Also mit eins und eins angefangen und dann ähm irgendwie damals schon irgendwelche Internetzugänge und danach dann irgendwie noch dann an die Börse gegangen, dann GMX gekauft äh und äh solche Scherze. Ja, inzwischen relativ
großer, wahrscheinlich der größte Player nach der Telekom, oder?
Würdest du mich auf mindestens einen linken Fuß erwischen? Auf jeden Fall jetzt kein kleiner Player, irgendwo muss er seine Kohle auch mitgemacht haben. Auf jeden Fall Ralph Dommermuth äh hat so ein bisschen die Geduld verloren.
Und will jetzt genauso etwas bauen, was die Bundesregierung wohl nicht hinbekommt, nämlich eine Netzgesellschaft für den flächendeckenden Gigabit-Internetaus,
Das folgt im Wesentlichen diesen Ideen, wie wir sie hier gerade beschrieben haben, wie wir sie im Übrigen auch schon bei Logbuch Netzpolitik zweihundert äh besprochen haben, als wir äh mit,
Äh Anke.
Anke und Daniel Dosch.
Daniel Domschaltberg äh gesprochen haben, die ja unter anderem neben ihren einem Miriade sonstigen politischen und aktivistischen Unternehmungen ja nebenbei ja auch nochmal irgendwie eine Glasfasercompany äh Versorgungskampagne starten wollen. Ähm.
Diese Idee ist halt einfach ein Nobrinner und genau das macht interessanterweise
Also hier soll quasi Infrastruktur gebaut, gebaut werden, also somit äh fallbar, tour the Building oder Tuso Home, also entweder äh bis in dein Haus oder bis äh in die Wohnung in deinem Haus,
und,
lädt andere Telekommunikationsfirmen ein, hier dieser Gesellschaft beizutreten, um dann eben eine gemeinsame Infrastruktur aufzubauen, die dann eben auch allen,
zu
gute Po, ne? Und das ist einfach genau das Modell und das ist das einzige Modell, was sinnvoll ist und was halt eigentlich der Staat hätte schon seit zehn Jahren machen müssen. Interessanterweise,
den Ausbau, den Gesamtbedarf Ausbau bei achtzig Milliarden Euro.
Ja und das kann klingt auch realistisch.
Klingt in meinen Augen auch viel realistischer. Ich meine, diese paar hundert Millionen Euro der letzten Regierungszeit war eh albern und jetzt,
Ich glaub langsam wird's auch dem Letzten klar. Also
irgendwie habe ich so das Gefühl, diese Debatte wird jetzt nicht mehr so lange auf einem vollkommen bekloppten Level geführt werden, sondern wir werden uns vermutlich äh demnächst dann auch noch über die Details unterhalten. Weil das war ja nun wirklich so beschämend,
ja, dass man dann einfach am laufenden Meter meint, Deutschland wäre jetzt irgendwie ein Infrastrukturkönig, was wir ja auch waren, ja, also ne.
Wann war das nochmal.
Neunziger Jahre, ich kann nur sagen, da gab es kein besseres Telefonnetz auf der Welt. Das das digitale Telefonnetz.
Also GSM, D eins oder was und D zwei.
Ist der.
Also EWSD, die Digitalisierung des Telefonnetzes in Deutschland, die ja in den achtziger Jahren vorangetrieben wurden, die so in den neunziger Jahren so richtig die Früchte äh dann äh hatten.
Ja ja stimmt, da haben die Amerikaner noch äh.
Da waren die noch nicht mal bei DSL und
da, da, da, da waren die noch so so richtig im Wald und und ISTN und äh zwei Megabit-Anschlüsse im Prinzip, die Multiplex-Anschlüsse und so. Das war schon alles geiles Zeug, das funktionierte gut. Ich
Ich meine, du konntest einen Telefonhörer abnehmen, du hast und mit dem Wählen der letzten Nummer
machte es tut auf der anderen Seite, du hattest einfach eine Verbindungsqualität, die war einfach Sahne, äh die Netzzufriedenstellung. Heute.
Hattest du Otti Fritz Card? Die Fritz ESDNCAR mit Kanalbündelung.
Hundertachtundzwanzig Kilo Bitte.
Hatte ich die Fritzkarte, es kann sein, ja. Ja, ich glaube ja.
Ich hatte ja, weiß ich nicht mehr so ganz und ich glaube ja.
So, natürlich war das im heutigen Vergleich viel zu teuer und ne, man musste irgendwie irre viel Geld äh dafür ausgeben. Nur da war, da waren wir eigentlich auf einem guten Weg.
Da waren wir noch wer.
Da hätte man, da hätte man den nächsten Schritt hat, machen wir so. Und die Telekom war ja sogar schon dabei. Ja, wir hatten ja in haben wir ja, glaube ich, auch schon ein paar Mal äh thematisiert, der schöne Begriff des Opal Ghettos, ja? Also.
Oh ja, die optische Anschlussleitung.
Genau, die optische Anschlussleitung. Das die war das Problem. Warum war die das Problem? Weil nämlich die Telekom gesagt hat, Glasfaser ist die Zukunft, das muss man sich mal vorstellen.
Anfang der neunziger Jahre war das die Politik. Optischer Anschluss, wir legen jetzt überall Glasfaser rein. Woran ist es dann gescheitert? Das.
Also ich kann das jetzt in Geld nicht richtig ausdrücken, aber das Problem auf dem Markt war natürlich,
dass Deutschland quasi allen voraus war und billige optische Last-Mile-Technik so noch nicht verfügbar waren. Natürlich waren die Kosten groß.
Und dann haben sie's halt schon mal gemacht. Friedrichshain war so ein äh eins dieser Opfer.
Hab ich zweitausend, Anfang der Zweitausender noch drunter gelitten unter dem Opalausbau.
Das Opal geht da unten, das ist irgendwie ein bisschen absurd, ne, dass man sagt, kein Internet, weil Glasfaser.
Die haben's am Ende nicht, äh muss man ja erklären warum, weil die es am Ende nicht hingekriegt haben, dass wieder äh die Wandlerdinger hinzukriegen, ne, die in den Keller mussten, oder?
Man ist halt nicht so ohne weitere. Also es ist halt ein Preis, der der Technik. Man hat halt damit gerechnet, dass der Markt mitzieht, ja.
So zu sagen, ja hallo hier. Äh wir wollen jetzt mal überall das neue Telekommunikationsnetz aufbauen, was halt jetzt Glasfaser ist und jetzt wird die Industrie halt langsam mal anfangen
Glasfaserboxen zu bauen, damit diese Kisten billig sind, damit wir die in die Wohnung reinstellen können, beziehungsweise zumindest schon mal in die Häuser reinstellen können. Das war eigentlich der Plan. Und das ist ja eigentlich auch
genau der richtige Plan. Problem ist nur, da sind die Amerikaner aufgewacht und haben gesagt, oh Internet hätten wir jetzt eigentlich auch ganz gerne mal. Was haben wir denn hier eigentlich? Und die hatten halt noch so richtig äh Mode im Realität, so richtig schlimm. Und dann fingen die halt an
DSL-Technik zu entwickeln und aus diesem Kupferhalt das Maximum rauszuholen. Und dann wurde das der totale Hype, weil natürlich die Nachfrage in den USA riesengroß war und natürlich auch die Bereitschaft äh im Internet zu investieren, riesig groß war, sodass sich halt der ganze Markt äh hin
dahin entwickelt hat, diese DSL-Technologie zu entwickeln
die dann sehr schnell sehr viel billiger wurde und dann stand die Telekom da mit ihrem Gasfaseranschluss für die keiner äh günstige Geräte bauen wollte, weil die sind ja auch abhängig davon, Indust,
konnten sie alles nicht selber finanzieren. Und dann hatten sie sozusagen ja die Samina nicht gehabt, dass einfach weiter durchzuziehen oder sich zumindest an hybriden Ansatz äh zu wählen, dass man sagt, okay, ja, scheiß drauf, jetzt haben wir hier zwar Opal, aber da.
Legen wir vielleicht die Kohle dann einfach mal selber drauf, um das jetzt durchzuziehen,
dann ist nun mal schon mal Glasfaser da und wir bauen auch weiterhin konsequent Glasfaser aus und wir sehen auch, dass dass die Zukunft das ist. Aber dieser Mut war nicht da,
oder das Geld oder die Bereitschaft oder was weiß ich oder die Weitsicht mit dem Ergebnis, dass das dann irgendwie alles dann nochmal also ich weiß nicht, ob das ein Rückbau war, aber es wurde ja dann quasi.
Nochmal aufgerissen und kurz war nochmal mit.
Gelegt, genau, damit dann eben alle Leute DSL haben können, damit sie überhaupt erstmal was haben, weil im Osten gab's ja teilweise einfach, da gab's halt einfach diese äh Kupferinfrastruktur, die der Westen so gut ausgebaut hatte, gab's ja nicht
Also hat man nochmal Kupfer reingelegt, damit man irgendwie dann darüber DSL machen kann. Bekloppt eigentlich, obwohl da halt schon Glasfaser überall auf der Straße rumlagen. Es ist wirklich zum Heulen. Na ja, auf jeden Fall schauen wir jetzt mal
was hier die GroKo im Angebot hat. Ähm ich habe so den Eindruck, dass der Wind sich dreht,
weil sie wissen einfach, dass sie jetzt mit den alten Modellen,
keine Plätze mehr gut machen können. Alle anderen Länder werden ihnen davon rennen,
Und nichts wird peinlicher sein als die alle drei Monate veröffentlichte Studie mit wo Deutschland jetzt so mit durchschnittlicher Anschlussgeschwindigkeit und so weiter liegt und Verfügbarkeit mit Netz im ländlichen Bereich. Ich muss auch sagen, dass sich auch die CDU überhaupt nicht verstehe, weil.
Konservativ hin, konservativ her. Wenn sie für irgendwas stehen, dann stehen sie für die Leute im ländlichen Bereich,
den tun die überhaupt keinen Gefallen.
Ja? Also das, dass sie da noch nicht mal in der Lage sind, ihre eigenen Klientel eigentlich das zu geben. Es mag daran liegen, dass die auch alle mittlerweile so alt sind, ihre Supporter.
Kein Internet brauchen.
Dass sie sich von diesem ach Internet, das ist doch dieser neumodische Scheiß äh.
Kann, ich glaube, das spielt tatsächlich eine Rolle.
Eine Riesenrolle so, ja, aber die müssen halt auch mal sehen, dass das auch die Leute Kinder haben und äh äh vielleicht dann eben auch da wohnen wollen und wenn sie diesem
Druck in die Städte halt irgendwas entgegensetzen wollen, dann müssen sie natürlich dafür sorgen, dass auch äh diese Orte zukunftstauglich sind
Beispiel hier Brandenburg, ja, die ein riesiges Problem haben mit einer Landflucht, ja? Alles zieht in den Gürtel um Berlin herum, sowohl Berliner ziehen von innen nach außen, weil hier die Preise steigen
Die Brandenburger ziehen aus den komplett abgehängten Bereichen. Du hast in diesen kleineren Ortschaften und Dörfern, kleineren Städten im Prinzip
hervorragende Bedingungen auch mal was Neues zu starten, weil die Lebenshaltungskosten da einfach so absurd niedrig sind, aber wenn du halt nicht für das Wichtigste sorgst und das Wichtigste ist
erstmal ähm.
Oberzentren zu schaffen, die irgendwie ihren Bereich versorgen. Also Oberzentren ist ja so ein stadtplanerischer Begriff, der sagt, da hast du irgendwie so ein Mindestmaß an Supermärkten et cetera und Basisversorgung von so dem täglichen Leben. Aber natürlich dann eben auch äh Stromwassergas, was in der Regel ja kein Problem ist.
Aber dann eben Internet, ja? Und ich bin ins Essen gefallen. Ich sage dir
Angela Merkel hat meinen Spruch, den ich seit zehn Jahren sage, gesagt. Ich sage das schon immer, Strom, Wasser,
Internet, das war immer mein Spruch und alle haben mich blöde angeguckt und dann schlage ich irgendwie so einen Artikel, aber ich habe jetzt leider den Link nicht zur Hand, dass die das genauso gesagt hat, dass ich fast.
Wir müssen das hier nur lange genug reden. Wir mü.
Nach zehn Jahren passt das. So und wo ist die Initiative, dass man sagt,
Wir machen jetzt mal diesen ländlichen Raum, diesen es gibt diesen Begriff, kennst du diesen Begriff sterbende Städte im äh in Ostdeutsch äh äh eine schrumpfende Städte, Entschuldig.
Ja, kannst du inzwischen kaufen, kannst ja, ja, letztens irgendwie einer im Dorf in Brandenburg für hunderttausend Euro gekauft. Ganzes Dorf. Weil da keiner mehr wohnt.
Ja Dorf, das waren so fünf Häuser. Aber.
Viel größer sind die in Brandenburg auch nicht.
Da ist, da ist einiges äh äh zu holen, ob du da was mit anfangen kannst, ist eine andere Frage. Ähm der Koffer wollte dann auch gleich wieder vom Kauf zurücktreten und so weiter. Das ist ein totales D.
Ja okay, aber also die Preise sind da.
So, aber ich meine, das das wäre eine Maßnahme, dass man einfach sagt, okay, alles klar. Dann schnappen wir uns doch jetzt hier mal diese Bereiche, ja? Und bauen da einfach mal konsequent Gasfahrer raus.
Fiber Village.
Und wir lassen uns nicht davon abhalten. Oh ja, aber wir wissen ja auch nicht, ob die Kunden dann das Internet haben wollen und die wollen ja alle gar kein schnelles Internet und so,
Leute, die werden das haben wollen, wenn sie endlich dann mal verstanden haben, dass sie komplett vom Leben abgeschnitten sind, wenn sie das nicht haben, ja? Dann könnt ihr ziemlich vergessen mit irgendwie der Bauernhof, der sein Online-Shopping mach.
Also ich kann mir auch sehr gut vorstellen, dass das äh sich äh innerhalb der nächsten Jahre.
Ein Bedarf entstehen könnte? An, sagen wir mal, weiter draußen in,
ländlicher, angenehmer Umgebung, befindlichen, günstigen.
Infrastruktur, Hubs. Also was weiß ich. Wir haben da draußen riesiges Gelände, ist anderthalb Stunden außerhalb von Berlin, hat aber Gigabit-Internet und da arbeiten wir,
Da ist unser Start-up äh erstmal einquartiert und äh du hast den ganzen, du hast den ganzen Trubel der Stadt nicht, du hast die ganzen aufgeblähten Mieten nicht und sitzt dafür irgendwie schön
in der in der Sonne.
An der Stelle fällt mir noch ein, können wir noch ein Kommentar aus den äh aus dem Feedback der letzten Sendung äh rausholen. Äh,
ein User mit dem schönen Nick nehmen. Evil Dan Wolles sagt zum Thema Farm vier null, das Tim Kurz erwähnte bei mir um die Ecke liegt Vechta Cloppenburg, eine recht starke Landwirtschaftsregion
Ich war vor einer Weile bei einer Industrie vier null Veranstaltung dort,
kleiner Einschub irgendwie wir auch mal diesen vier null Termin äh eingebracht hat, gehört auch öffentlich ausgepeitscht. Und,
Die Bude war voll mit Landwirten, die von den anwesenden Politikern Wirtschaftsförderern und Technologen lautstark LTE auf ihren Äckern forder
Die Landmaschinen haben alle seit Jahren Bordcomputer mit GPS und die Bauern wollen online auf ihre Datenbanken mit den Düngemittelausbringungen erträgen et cetera zugreifen
Kühe, die mit RFID Chips, Futterautomaten öffnen, die dann prüfen, wie viel welches Tier frisst und bei Auffälligkeiten Bescheid geben, sind ebenso real im Einsatz wie Kamerasysteme, die auf der Erntemaschine in Echtzeit das Verhältnis von Spinatstil
zu zu Spinatblatt. Äh erkennen und den äh Bedienern andere Messerhöhen empfehlen.
Geht noch weiter. Also diese Ausbringung der Saat äh GPS gesteuert nach Betrachtung der Bodenverhältnisse äh Ausprägung der Dünger, also es ist quasi.
Die war sie vorher mit Drohnen, mit Infrarotkameras und.
Drohnen, Drohnensysteme, die vor der vor dem Trecker herfliegen äh und gucken, ob da irgendwas noch ist und so, wenn du dann irgendwie wenn der Bauer betrunken ist und Pferd nochmal über seine eigene Spur
ja? Dann geht der ähm schalten die automatisch die Düsen ab
Damit du da nicht nochmal mehr Gift drauf streust, damit du halt quasi gleichmäßig auf dem Boden aufgebaut. Weil letztes Jahr mal die äh Agritechnica
Treckermesse in Hannover besucht. Da gibt's äh feine feine Gerätschaften. Ja, die brauchen da alle Internet für weil die alle natürlich dann das äh Bauertablet haben wollen, ne, wo sie äh fahren will, spielen können
und alles schön zentral haben. Melkroboter ganz zu schweigen.
Und es gibt jetzt auch schon Elektrotraktoren und so.
Die habe ich nicht gesehen. Aber oder habe ich nicht so drauf geachtet, aber.
So, John Deere, andere, weil weil die nämlich auch merken, dass das eine Menge Vorteile hat, ne? Also Lärm,
Umweltverschmutzung mag jetzt nicht so ganz äh das Primärding sein in ländlichen Regionen, weil da ist ja nicht so viel Stadt drum rum, aber äh Lautstärke ist auf jeden Fall ein Ding, weil du kannst dann halt auch noch später am Abend irgendwie äh wenn dann noch ähm andere,
Leute wohnen in der Nähe, kannst du noch äh arbeiten, um von Autonomie mal äh ganz zu schweigen
und natürlich hast du optimale Aufladebedingungen, weil das Ding steht in der Scheune, da hast du dann deine,
und äh Bronze keine große Infrastruktur dafür, die ist leicht zu machen und amortisiert sich halt auch schnell
Also da ist eine ganze Menge in Bewegung und dieses Verständnis, dass man halt äh diese Region äh da äh geradezu mit.
Breite pimpen muss,
einfach mal klar. In China läuft das jetzt so, da hast dann so in Armbauernregion, wo die vor zehn Jahren noch am Rumhungern waren. Da fährst du in die Stadt rein, da hängen da riesige Plakate, wo draufsteht. Onlineshopping ist toll, macht alle Onlineshopping. Und zwar gemeint ist nicht,
Shoppt alle online, sondern vershoppt euren Scheiß online und das heißt, da werden sozusagen diese
Gebiete, damit's halt nicht noch mehr Druck in die Städte gibt, was ja in China schon ziemlich extrem ist, geradezu daran an dazu angehalten, selber online auch selber mit ihren eigenen Produkten et cetera, was sie da bauen, machen äh,
aktiv zu werden und teilweise die Branche zu wechseln oder vielleicht einfach nur das, was sie bisher gemacht haben, einem größeren Markt zuzuführen. Und natürlich,
wird das begleitet von einer entsprechenden Netzinfrastruktur Maßnahme. Also ich habe ehrlich gesagt, ich habe gar keine,
kein Bock mehr, das Thema auch nur ein einziges Mal hier nochmal aufzudröseln. Reicht jetzt. Ich habe so einen Hals und äh,
Hört euch einfach die anderen Sendungen an, wenn es immer noch nicht.
Hört euch einfach die anderen zweihundertsechsundvierzig Sendungen an, indem wir das auch nochmal erklä.
Das das Ding muss jetzt einfach sitzen. Das ist eure letzte Chance
Ansonsten wird's einfach nur noch lächerlich und albern. Und dann müsst ihr euch ordentlich nicht wundern, äh über die Konsequenzen, die das haben wird. Das ist einfach genauso wie diese ganze Elektro äh Dieseldebatte,
sorry, aber in vier Jahren haben wir andere Themen.
Und genau, aber ja. Kommen wir, kommen wir zu den Kurzmeldungen.
Jetzt nur noch eine halbe Stunde pro Thema.
Ich mach's wirklich kurz. Also in der ähm Türkei zum Einsatz gekommen ähm ein,
und erstmals richtig nachgewiesen wieder vom Citysin-Lab dem Team um Professor Deibert an der Mankschool of Global Affairs der University To,
Ronto. Ähm die jetzt festgestellt haben in der Türkei kam also ähm zum ersten Mal auch in der Breite.
Oder in dem Moment ist es jetzt Türkei oder ja ne, weil es war türkischer Provider.
Ach so, aber ich glaube ne.
Türkei auch.
Ähm ein ähm hat einen Provider, so schöne seine DPI-Boxen darauf getrimmt, den Download von Software äh in die Infektion,
umzuwandeln. Das heißt, man lädt also irgendwie eine ähm man will irgendwie eine Software runterladen.
Und da sitzt da eine ob beim Provider, ein eine Kiste im Regal, die per DPI checkt, ob man gerade diesen Zugriff zum Download dieser Datei macht.
Also DPE, die Packet Inspection ist gemeint.
Also schaut in der Sekunde, aha, da will jetzt gerade jemand äh hier werden VLC Player für Windows runterladen, dann wird dieser eine Rick Fest spezifisch nur der umgeleitet auf eine andere Version.
Ähm.
Mitten einer, mit einer Infektion. Also in diesem Fall ähm Spyware Programm äh Strong, Pitty äh steht hier. Ähm.
Also quasi eine infizierte Binary wird dann da äh runtergeschoben und der Rechner, der der Kunde installiert sie. Ähm,
Das gibt es schon länger. Interessant ist, dass das hier zum ersten Mal wirklich in der Breite ähm mit mit vielen.
Menschen ähm nachgewiesen wurde. Finn Fischer hat das schon vor Ewigkeiten, also Gamma, Finn Fischer, das zur,
Möglichkeit zur Anbringung ihres äh Staatstroaners schon weiß ich nicht vor wie vielen Jahren beworben. Ist jetzt auch nichts,
Neues, dass man diese Angriffe macht. Äh warum ich das hier nochmal erwähne ist, um das zu verhindern.
Nutzt man signierte Softwareupdates, um das zu verhindern ähm,
wandert das jetzt in unsere Betriebssysteme, dass sie sagen, wir wollen, dass das von identifizierten Developern ist und so weiter
Dummerweise natürlich, wenn da ein staatlicher Akteur hinterhängt, ähm dann kann er natürlich auch äh im Zweifelsfall sich zumindest valide Zertifikate,
wieder generieren und dann ist eben euer Fauls, wäre euer VC Player so eher ordnungsgemäßig signiert ist und signatur geprüft wird eben von,
irgendeinem staatlichen Unternehmen signiert, aber Besorgnis erregend, dass hier ähm.
Eher so im Bereich der Hunderte,
Infektion stattgefunden haben und man hier nicht mehr gezielt vorgeht. Das heißt schlecht sieht es aus.
Türkei. Und der Einsatz solcher Technik äh haben wir immer vor gewarnt.
Dann ähm Plädoyeren inzwischen,
Datenschützer äh sehr spezifisch für eines der Ziele, was der Chaos-Computerclub primär äh Frank und ich äh schon seit geraumer Zeit,
versuchen zu forcieren oder voranzubringen, nämlich dass man sagt.
Wenn du eine ein, so ein IOT-Gerät oder überhaupt ein Gerät in die Welt setzt, dann musst du dafür so und so lange,
Softwareupdates liefern, um insbesondere, was die Sicherheit angeht. Zweite Forderung
du musst Sicherheitsupdates von Feature ab oder Feature Downgrades trennen, ja? Also nicht irgendwie äh in der nächsten Version nehmen wir ihnen ein Feature wieder weg, dafür gibt's mehr Sicherheit oder so
und vor allem unsere zentrale Forderung, wenn du dann aufhörst,
Als Provider, dieses Gerät, also als als Hersteller, dieses Gerät zu supporten. Was ja irgendwann.
Sicherlich mal aus ökonomischen Erwägungen der Fall ist. Dann bitte Quellkraut freigeben damit,
eine Community sich weiter um den Support dieses Gerätes kümmern kann
ja, dann dann unterstützt du eben, was weiß ich, den den Fritzbox-Router oder die, die nicht mehr. Wunderbar. Dann gibst du den Quellcode frei, sodass dann eben ähm eine,
eine weitere Pflege stattfinden kann. Sei es nur, dass die bestehende Software,
Härtefall gepatcht wird oder sei es, dass das Gerät sich angeeignet wird und dann eben ein Open-Wear-Tee draufgefahren wird und äh so ein
weiterhin noch sehr gut verwenden, technisch weiterhin verwendbares Produkt, nicht in den Müll wandern muss oder ein äh Risiko.
Für die Infrastruktur, Sicherheit wird. Also, diese Forderung jetzt auch von,
einer Datenschützerversammlung, nämlich die internationale Arbeitsgruppe zum Datenschutz in der Telekommunikation ähm als Empfehlung.
Herausgegeben, das heißt, das geht jetzt auch langsam in die Breite und das wäre schön, dass irgendwann mal.
Zeitnah zu sehen, dass diese Forderungen auch wirklich äh Anklang fin.
Also da muss ich ja mal dazu sagen, das ist natürlich jetzt leicht gefordert, aber äh selbst bei bestem Willen schwierig äh durchzuführen, ne, weil das setzt ja voraus, dass da ein ähm dass dein
Source Code auch sich veröffentlichen lässt.
Du kannst es ja auch gerne weiter supporten und nicht veröffentlichbaren Source Code haben, aber
Spezifisch reden wir ja hier ähm primär hat sich diese Debatte ja entfaltet, er entfacht an Plastikrouten. Also äh Plasterrooter und IOT-Kram
Und gerade diese Geräte, da geht ja keiner hin und entwickelt das alles neu, das in der sind in der Regel irgendwelche abgespeckten ähm äh Linux and Bad Systeme. Da wird das Rad selten neu erfunden.
Und ähm das hält natürlich auch in der Regel die Produktionskosten gering, dass dass man da eben größtenteils auf Open Source Software setzen kann.
Man sitzt auf, Open Source Software, aber man sitzt ja unter Umständen auch auf eine ganze Menge nicht, Open Source Software, also es können ja spezielle Treiber sein, wo man dann sozusagen überhaupt gar nicht die Möglichkeit hat
das zu veröffentlichen, weil der Willist Chip sozusagen, da muss da die Treiber von Qualkompe verwenden und der darf aber nicht veröffentlicht werden.
Längst gelöst, äh das wird ja heute schon geklärt, dass insbesondere diese äh Chip äh Fernwehr als Bine Reblock dann eben bereitgestellt wird ähm zur Weiter.
Sagen nachzuladen, was äh ja gut, aber dann ist natürlich mit dem Support so eine Sache, weil was ist, wenn der dann halt äh nicht äh funktioniert, dann funktioniert halt auch alles andere nicht. Ähnliches Ding mit User in der Face speziell.
Deswegen ja die deswegen ja die Erzwingung. Ich, also mir geht's ja um mir geht's ja um erstmal nur um den Verbraucherschutz. Wenn ich ein Gerät kaufe.
Da möchte ich da dran stehen haben, wie lange der Hersteller sich für dieses Gerät noch verantwortlich fühlt,
Wenn das Geräte sind, bei denen nicht eingepreist ist und nicht vorgesehen ist, dass der ähm Hersteller sich die für dieses Gerät noch verantwortlich fühlt
Dann haben wir solche äh Mira kompatiblen Geräte äh die zwei Jahre später in riesigen Botnetzen hängen und uns das Leben schwer machen.
So, das heißt, das darf nicht passieren. Mindest, Mindestsupportdauer.
Bezieht sich denn diese Forderung.
Darf ich ganz kurz. So, zweitens.
Jetzt ist das Ende dieser Mindestsupportdauer erreicht. Das heißt, der Hersteller des Herstellenunternehmen sagt so, wir bringen nicht mehr die Aufwände, dieses Produkt zu pflegen. Das heißt, wir dieses Produkt ist jetzt,
End of Life. Ja? Was bei einem Produkt wie bei einem Softwareprodukt wie Microsoft Windows völlig vertretbar, nachvollziehbar und so weiter ist, dass man nach dreizehn Jahren Minus XP sagt, jetzt.
Hören wir auf damit. Wer wer jetzt noch dieses ein Betriebssystem haben möchte, greife bitte auf andere unserer Produkte zurück. Gerne,
völlig okay. Schwierig wird das in dem Moment, wo diese Software Unterstützungsentscheidung.
An ein sich physisch manifestierendes Gerät gebunden ist. In diesem Fall eben ein Router oder ein IOT-Gerät,
welches unter Umständen nach all diesen vielen Jahren immer noch sich sinnvoll betreiben lässt bis dann die nächste ähm Schwachstelle den Betrieb,
nicht mehr möglich oder nicht mehr verantwortlich macht. Und in diesem Fall möchte ich einfach nur als Verbraucher wissen, ähm,
Dieses Stück Hardware, was ich hier gekauft habe, muss ich nicht, wenn die Software, wenn wenn der Hersteller aufhört, die Software zu unterstützen, in den Müll werden. Das ist auch eine ökologisch
notwendige Förderung, Förderung. Ja, wenn du jetzt hier von irgend so einem Lichtschalter oder so einem Heizungsthermostat oder ein Gateway dafür, oder äh eben einen Plastikrouter, der zu Hause steht,
redest, dass dann gesagt wird, okay, wenn der Hersteller aufhört, dann sorgt er dafür, dass es in irgendeiner Form Open Source weitergepflegt werden kann.
Ich will nochmal einschränken meine.
Anmerkungen bezogen sich auch generell auf so eine Produkt äh Haftung.
Was ich ein bisschen übersehen hatte, hast du wahrscheinlich gesagt, ist, hier geht's ja konkret um.
Internet of Things, Embette Systeme, die eben High Connectivity haben und permanent sozusagen in offenen oder zumindest teiloffenen oder potentiell offenen Netzen herumlungern und,
ja, das sehe ich auch genauso, das muss eigentlich auch passieren, weil ansonsten wird es für dich ein,
ein Wahnsinn mit mit diesen ganzen
Devices, die dann irgendwie rumgammeln und einfach äh Opfer sind. Das wird ganz interessant sein, zu sehen, was das auch nochmal so für Implikationen hat, weil natürlich auch diese gesamte äh.
Aktualisierbar Infrastruktur. Ich meine, dieses Nerd kann Devevice nehmen und selber aktualisieren, indem er sich auf komplexer Webseite irgendwas zusammenbaut. Dass das eine, das andere ist ja.
Das wird.
Ein universeller Firmenwehraktualisierungsstandard, der sozusagen auch äh herstellerübergreifend funktioniert und auch von der Community
ein anderer interessanter Schritt, ne, was sozusagen da auch ein entsprechendes Sicherheitsmodell dahinter äh steht und äh man ein, ein Pool an frei verfügbarer
Firma und Updates hat, an denen auch alle Geräte teilnehmen können ohne dass man sich zu sehr drauf verlassen können muss, dass die.
Hersteller der Originalsoftware das auch richtig hinbekommen haben, ne?
Wenn die Hersteller da ein bisschen.
Klug wären. Können sie sich da viel abschauen? Nämlich im Prinzip gemeinsam ihre Ressourcen auch bündeln, um zu sagen, okay, die Basis,
Was weiß ich das? Linux da drunter, den Webserver, der, der das äh Interfest macht. Das entwickeln wir einmal,
bedienen uns da alle einer gleichen Plattform. Um und können dadurch einfach schon mal sicherstellen, dass sich mal so die die schweren Schnitzer,
im im gemeinsamen Prozess gebündelt geupdatet werden können. Ähm, man kann sich dann darüber Gedanken machen.
Hm, wir sind ja in den Diskussionen auch schon ein bisschen weiter. Dann kommen so Fragen wie, ja, aber wenn wir ähm wenn wir,
nicht.
Wenn wir schadhafte, wenn wir für die Sicherheit des Gerätes sorgen wollen, dann müssen wir natürlich auch signierte Updates machen. Und wenn wir signierte Updates erzwingen, dann kann den können Nutzer nicht mehr so einfach eigene
Fernwehr hochladen. Dann kann man also sich darüber Gedanken machen, okay so ein Hardware-Switch zu machen. Alles gelöste Probleme
Die jetzt, also gab's ja bei den Crown-Box. Ich weiß nicht, ob's das immer noch so ist. Ähm alles gelöste Probleme.
Die man jetzt in die Tat umsetzen könnte und da muss einfach mal von Seiten der Regulierung der entsprechende Zwang her, der entsprechende Anreiz her, dass man sich für ökonomische Möglichkeiten
bereitet dieser diesem Anspruch gerecht zu werden. Denn dem gerecht zu werden ist nicht schwierig. Ähm.
Das heißt natürlich auch nicht, dass dann sofort überall eine Open Source Community entsteht, die sagt, okay, wir pflegen jedes noch so dämliche Gerät jetzt hier weiter,
Aber was ich mir vorstellen könnte, ist, dass durchaus sollte dann einmal in so einem End-Off-Support-Gerät eine dicke Sicherheitslücke klaffen,
Leuten zu zum Problem wird, dass dann tatsächlich mal schnell äh der ein oder andere schlaue Kunde,
oder der andere ein oder andere Wohltäter in der Mittagspause den Code auscheckt und sagt alles klar, ich habe die, die Walnobility ist hier, ich fixie mal eben.
Oder dass zumindest die Gritte in so einen zuverlässigen ich bin nicht mehr sicher, ich funktioniere jetzt nicht mehr, tausche mich aus Modus äh wechseln.
Das ne, das könnte auch sein, das wird natürlich dann bei kritischen Geräten wieder äh schwierig. Da gibt's viele Sachen. Wichtig ist einfach nur unsere Situation ist, dass viel.
Schrott in unsere in unsere in unsere Wohnzimmer gespült wird wo,
Allein schon am Preis erkenntlich ist, dass der Hersteller nicht vorsieht bei diesem Gerät noch irgendeine Form der Nachsorge zu betreiben. Und das ist das erste wichtige Ziel, Support, Zwang, Update, Zwang mitgenannter,
Zeitdauer. Und es ist weiterhin klar, dass diese Zeitdauer begrenzt sein muss
Man kann nicht sagen, so du hast ein Gerät verkauft, äh lieber Hersteller, du bist jetzt bis ins siebte Glied deiner Familie haftbar, für jeden, für jedes ungemacht, was von diesem Gerät ausgeht und du musst innerhalb eines Tages äh Security-Updates bis ans äh
bis bis an unser aller Tage Ende bereitstehen ist klar. Ja? Wird dann doch bitte zu sagen, okay, dann sag doch, wie lange du möchtest,
Nehmen wir eine, sage ich mal, eine Zeitraum von fünf bis zehn Jahren. Was ich jetzt so,
sage ich mal für zumutbar, erachte und dann ist das Gerät eh so alt, ähm dass du, dass du wahrscheinlich eh komplett neue Gerätegenerationen hast und dann sagst du einmal hier.
Gib Push. Wer jetzt noch was damit machen soll äh möchte, kann das tun. Ähm wir wollen in das Gerät nicht mehr investieren,
Also sagen wir uns auch los von allem äh Sonstigen. So. Wäre doch mal eine Möglichkeit.
Entstehen natürlich wie gesagt dann dann sagen natürlich auch die die Open Source Community wie jetzt sollen wir den ganzen Schrott der soll hier bei uns abgeladen werden
Und da könnten könnten die Geräte dann weiterhin punkten zu sagen, hier wir geloben, dass dieses Gerät nach zehn Jahren ähm,
kompatibel,
sein wird und zwar in der jetzt aktuellen Variante, die für die es, sagen wir mal, wie bei so einem Ubundtun, Longtime Support gibt, den wiederum wir als Hersteller pflegen. Also da kann man doch.
Ja und vor allem Open Source heißt ja nicht, dass man damit kein Geld verdienen kann. Also das da kann man sich ja durchaus vorstellen, dass man dann sozusagen sagt, na ja okay, es gibt jetzt hier äh,
Firmen, die auf Basis von Open Source,
bleibt alles offen und wer kann und will, kann sich das auch irgendwie alles selber zusammenbacken und es ist auch nach wie vor alles über,
und so weiter. Aber wer quasi an diesem Modus teilhabt, kann halt auch eine Support-Firma aufmachen
Oder kann ich halt mein Device einstellen, auf hol dir mal die die Updates von da, weil die haben einen guten Neumund und da zahle ich irgendwie pro Device, zehn Cent pro Monat, et cetera, fällt jetzt die Laube und schon hast du da auch einen Revenus-Stre.
Könnte es als Hersteller äh vielleicht sogar soweit gehen, zu sagen, alles klar, wir bauen hier Geräte, die äh wir spenden
Betrag X im Jahr an das Open WRT Projekt, ja? Dafür verkaufen wir Geräte, die wir ab, die wir mit dem reinen Open VRT vorflashen,
und ähm.
Übernimmt dann den, ihr macht sozusagen, ihr übernimmt den Support von uns, wir sind raus, aber ihr seid auch finanziert, alles möglich.
Ja, und dann zahlt ihr, dann kauft der Kunde ein schönes Gerät, ähm was äh was äh was er der Features wegen kauft und ähm da kann man also viele Möglichkeiten äh gibt's immer auch Probleme dran, aber,
alles ist besser als das, was wir jetzt haben. Deswegen freuen wir uns, dass diese Forderung übernommen wurde.
So, dann haben wir einen wiederkehrendes Thema und auch in den zukünftigen Sendungen sicherlich häufig wiederkehrendes Thema ist, äh sind die Upload-Filter.
EU will sie ja gerade voranbringen, EU-Kommission empfiehlt ja ein ein sicheres Internet mit mit schönen Upload-Filtern an zentraler Stelle von den großen Unterhalten. Ähm letzte Sendung haben wir ausführlich drüber gesprochen.
Und jetzt haben wir hier ähm,
die Kampagne beziehungsweise die das Blog Pink Dings Vielfalt ist Schönheit, die ein äh Video gemacht haben, Not Heidis Girl mit so einer,
Kampagne, die sich auch gegen diese,
GNT Germany, Snacks Topmodel, äh Quatsch da und die,
alles was man daran kritisieren kann, können wir ganze Sendung drüber machen, warum das alles stuss ist. Ähm haben sie sich eben gegen das äh Menschenbild, was von dieser Sendung da propagiert wird, gewennt und haben ein Video gemacht und eine Kampagne gemacht. Not Heidis Girl. So, jetzt wurde.
Ähm dieses dieses Video hat irgendwie äh enorme äh,
Klickzahlen bei YouTube erlangt, äh irgendwie siebenhunderttausend Mal äh riesige Resonanz von Lehrerinnen, Mädchengruppen, Presse, ne, unendlich viel Arbeit reingesteckt, äh tolle Kampagne äh gebracht und
dann kommt RTL und äh packt dieses Video,
In ihren Sennen, in ihre Sendung, ne? In irgendeiner RTL-Sendung, ich weiß nicht, welche, weil ich RTL nicht gucke und,
Genauso wie in anderen Fernsehsendern. Ähm aber dann wurde dieses Video quasi bei RTL ausgestrahlt. Sie haben dann sogar noch irgendwie über das Logo von Pink Stings ihren ihren blöden RTL da drauf gemacht und dann,
ging in der Nacht zum sechzehnten Februar der Fingerprintbott von RTL,
über seine eigenen RTL-Inhalte und hat gesagt, ah hier, dieses Video ist offenbar von uns, von RTL und hat es automatisiert bei YouTube gemeldet,
Woraufhin YouTube dann ungeprüft 'ne Content ID Beschwerde quasi entgegengenommen hat und das Video von denen offline genommen hat aufgrund einer Urheberrechtsbeschwerde von RTL.
Geil, ne?
So und äh ist aber.
Sagen der RTL sagt ja sorry.
Mit der Kauensperre oder erstmal nur.
Das Video war dann wohl nur einige Stunden. Ähm.
Offline, aber sie schreiben natürlich auch in ihrem Blogpost, ist natürlich äh tödlich, wenn so eine Kampagne gerade mal läuft und abgeht, das sind die wichtigen Stunden gewesen, ja und ähm.
Ja
Und äh das nur eines von vielen Beispielen, die jeden Tag äh passieren. Mit passiert das regelmäßig, dass sich
wenn ich irgendwo im Fernsehbeitrag ein Interview gebe, na? Und ich den irgendwo nochmal finde dann nehme ich den Beitrag gerne mal und schneide den da raus
wenn der jetzt zum besonders aktuellen Thema war oder besonders wichtig mach,
ab und zu mal. Letzter auf YouTube hoch, kannst du auch regelmäßig davon ausgehen, dass der wieder weg ist. Aber nur bei diesem privaten, bei öffentlich-rechtlichen, die machen das nicht
weshalb ich privat inzwischen auch irgendwie weniger häufig Interviews gebe, weil äh die dann mir meine eigenen das Recht am eigenen Wort absprechen.
Lino ist nur noch ein Podcasts.
Tja, also.
Dass das.
Dass das der Schaden ist da jetzt. Ich meine, man kann natürlich genauso gut sagen, äh,
das Video wurde halt jetzt weiter verbreitet, stellt euch mal nicht so an, aber darum geht's hier eben nicht. Es geht da darum, dass die ihre Arbeit hatten, dass,
Sie das Urheberrecht an diesem Video haben, das und das RTL, der es mehr oder weniger einfach äh weggestohlen hat. Außer.
Jahren fand Pink Stings hätte jetzt nicht so ohne Weiteres eine Urlauberrechtsverletzung bei RTL.
Melden können, genau und dann sagen steht hier noch ein Bot darf gar keine Urhebersverletzung mehr hätten, das dürfen nur reelle Personen. Wir hätten also klagen können, da wir aber kein
da wir aber keinen finanziellen Schaden nachweisen können, der Schaden ist ja nur ideell.
Ist unklar, ob die Auskunftspflicht greifen würde und da wir mit fünf Leuten da dreißig Stunden eh immer an der Überlastungsgrenze arbeiten, haben wir uns dagegen entschieden.
So sieht's aus, wenn man sagt, die Größeren können nochmal eben die Sachen klären.
So haben wir noch so eine richtig kurze so wie die anderen.
Ein Thema, was ich ähm was wir bisher glaube ich noch nicht behandelt haben. Äh wenn dann nur am Rande,
ist ähm die Polizei auf Twitter. Polizei auf Twitter äh.
Hat nämlich die Praxis entwickelt ab und mal den ein oder anderen Nutzer zu blocken. Ne?
Wenn du da jetzt mal protestierst und sagst, hallo Polizei, das finde ich aber nicht in Ordnung, dass ihr hier
diesen Menschen, der friedlich protestiert hat, das Augenlicht genommen habt, am Stuttgart einundzwanzig oder so, ne, dann könntest du ja gerne mal sage ich mal so den ein oder anderen
Reflex auslösen, dass der die der Polizist oder die Polizistin, die da gerade äh am Account ist.
Den Blockknopf drückt.
Und jetzt würde man natürlich bin spontan sagen, na ja ist doch äh gute Recht, das gute Recht. Äh eines jeden auf Twitter zu blocken, wen sie möchte.
Ist aber nicht so, denn äh diese Twitter äh Profile der Polizei agieren da natürlich irgendwo
im absolut rechtlichen Graubereich, ne? Da da braucht man sich über die Datenschutzbestimmungen, denn so eine Behörde ohnehin unterliegt, erstmal gar nicht zu wundern,
Denn was hier natürlich die Rolle spielt, sind die Informationsfreiheitsansprüche der Bürger,
Und wie sieht das denn dann aus, wenn die Polizei jetzt sagt, Altstrafe dafür,
dass du unsere Einsatztaktik kritisiert hast oder vielleicht auch einfach nur ein Journalist bist, der einen unschönen Artikel über uns geschrieben hat.
Keine Katastrophenmeldung mehr für d.
Darfst du nicht mehr gucken äh wie wie angenehm und witzig wir sind, weil wir dich lieben.
Ja oder irgendwie auch Warnung und Hinweise nicht mehr zur Kenntnis nehmen.
Ja genau. Was ist denn hier? Warnung und Hinweise, Falschparker auf der A3.
Ja, da ist grade brennt gerade eine Fabrik bei dir um die Ecke irgendwie bleiben, ne?
Bleiben sie in ihren Häusern? Na es verstand zu keinem Zeitpunkt eine Gefahr für die Bevölkerung.
Ja und vor allem wenn die das stört, können sie ja immer noch irgendwie mythen. Also es gibt ja kein Recht da, wie die Hinweise entgegenzunehmen, die da gesendet werden, aber äh Blocken heißt ja, wie direktionales Sperren.
Genau, blocken ist äh.
Also die weniger sinnvolle Methode und ähm da gab es dann auch eine eine Anstrengung der GFF,
das Ding mal auseinanderzunehmen und durch Beschwerden.
Auf eine Musterklage hinzu wirken ähm wo ich, sage ich mal.
Sage ja, also schön und gut, ne? Aber äh unsere Freiheit.
Wird sicherlich auch an anderen Stellen äh verteidigt, als jetzt unbedingt dabei bei der von der Polizei ähm Getwitter zu äh äh gebloggt zu werden auf Twitter. Nichtsdestotrotz ist das natürlich ein sehr wichtiger ähm.
Ein sehr wichtiger Aspekt und auch da muss sich mal jemand drum kümmern und diese,
offenkundig, rechtswidrigen Treiben, ein Ende bereiten und für die GFF ist das natürlich auch mit geringerem Aufwand,
mit für die GFF ist das mit geringem Aufwand verbunden, da mal sowas mal schnell von den von den Gerichten wegklagen zu lassen mit anderen Worten eine niedrig hängende Frucht.
Und äh und eben auch so ein juristisch wichtiger Punkt, da mal äh Klarheit zu schaffen, in welchem Graubereich da überhaupt diese äh Polizeibehörden mit diese.
Mit diesen Accounts agieren. Ich hab damit.
Wobei ich sagen muss, ich finde das okay, dass sie dabei sind so. Also ich finde äh ist absolut wichtig und richtig, dass die Polizei da an diesem öffentlichen Diskurs äh teilnimmt.
Wie sie's macht, ist äh ja Glocken geht gar nicht.
Aber wie sie's macht und welchen Regeln sie da unterworfen ist, ist sicherlich diskussionswürdig und es ist sicherlich auch noch nicht alles zu Ende
gedacht, weil das halt einfach auch einfach ein neues, neues Feld ist, ne. Aber ich finde es generell okay, auch äh eine Polizeikompetenz äh zu haben, die dann halt auch im Zeitfall einfach mal ein paar Fragen beantworten kann. So, warum nicht, ne? Also, so Polizei hilft äh
ja heute Blattmöglichkeiten sich in der Popularität noch vor Telekom hilft einzureihen.
Ja, also es gibt natürlich dann noch äh sehr viele Berichterstattungen darüber
wie denn da so die Polizei agiert, ne? Also Markus Reuter hat das äh beobachtet das ja seit äh längerer Zeit bei Netzpolitik Org und ähm stellt natürlich auch
regelmäßig fest, dass sie äh zum Beispiel da auch Falschmeldungen verbreiten, ne? Also da gab's ja dann irgendwie diese diese Geschichte, dass sie bei einer,
ähm Räumung äh irgendwie mal behauptet haben äh die die Türklinke stünde unter Strom,
oder dass sie diese Moloko.
War doch diese Räumung direkt nach G zwanzig, ne? In Berlin.
Ich mein das wäre früher gewes.
Nee, das war so genau das Wochenende danach, wo dann nämlich diese Truppe, die sie vorher in Hamburg weggeschickt haben zum Einsa.
Ach so, die wollen ja.
Und äh weiß auch die da die äh die Partysause da gemacht haben im Vorfeld.
Ja die.
Sich klugerweise so aus diesem ganzen Schlamassel rauszuholen, eigentlich einen ganz guten Strategie. Aber die waren dann halt irgendwie äh Neukölln oder so bei einer Räumung,
im Einsatz und da kam dann diese Sache mit dieser elektronischen, mit dieser elektrischen Türklinke der angeblichen zu Tage. Na ja.
Da haben sie also da die Dementicom dann halt relativ spät, gibt's also hier nochmal einen schönen äh also das, das wird dann der nächste Teil, wo man sich damit auseinandersetzen muss, weil da natürlich, wenn die da mal irgendwie so einen Stuss äh
eine Falschmeldung twittern, dass irgendwie auch anders gewertet und gewichtet wird, als wenn jetzt äh als wenn sie in einer Pressemitteilung äh die Unwahrheit behaupten, ne.
Da da ist also da gibt es noch viel zu regeln und da auch da muss sich jemand drum kümmern.
Also es darf auf keinen Fall darf.
Dass so ein zu so einem Propaganda und Marketinginstrument werden, ja?
Ist es aber auf jeden F.
Das ist es derzeit sicherlich im Wesentlichen,
Meinetwegen können sie gerne äh twittern, dass da irgendein Hundebaby gefunden wurde und dass sie das jetzt irgendwie wieder nach Hause gebracht haben und so, auch wenn das so schon so ein bisschen so einen Schmonzettenbereich äh reingeht, aber äh generell
diese Öffentlichkeit zu nutzen, um Dinge öffentlich zu machen, die auch öffentlich gehören, ja?
Meinetwegen auch eine eine Fahndung, wenn die sozusagen an sich gerechtfertigt ist und äh rechtlich ausreichend abgesichert ist, dann ist das alles supi, aber wenn's jetzt nur noch darum geht, äh zu sagen, auch hier kommen
Äh haben alle schöne Knutschmünder und und ne, mit Duckface äh vom Wohnungsbrand. Das.
Muss ja ein Ende finden und zwar schnell.
Und da hängt äh eben die GF dran, da gibt's Berichte drüber und dann gibt es jetzt auch gerade, weil das Thema eben hochkochte und da natürlich allein durch die Frage äh dadurch, dass sich die GFF da mal drangewendet hat, weil dann
die GFF sich dann eben ihre Muster äh betroffenen aussucht und dann wenden die sich eben an die Polizei,
stellen und sagen, sie betreiben diesen Account. Erklären sie uns doch jetzt mal bitte, warum,
unser Mandant hier von ihnen gesperrt wurde
und dann müssen die ja quasi das begründen. Und dann hast du äh quasi da hast du natürlich die absurdesten äh Begründungen drin und dann kannst du dagegen schön,
Knagen. Da wurden wurden natürlich jetzt der ein oder andere äh Dienststellenleiter oder Datenschutz und Informationsfreiheitsbeauftragter bei der Polizei äh aufmerksam und dann haben hat der deutsche,
Der wissenschaftliche Dienst des deutschen Bundestages
Dazu auch direkt noch ein Gutachten veröffentlicht, wo er drin argumentiert, dass das Blockieren von Nutzern in sozialen Medien ein Grundrechtseingriff darstellt. Äh wenn nämlich dieses Polizeikonto jemanden auf Facebook oder Twitter den Zugang,
verwehrt oder erschwert, behindern sie damit das Recht auf Informationsfreiheit des Nutzers und äh damit hm.
Ist quasi hier jetzt auch schon mal durch das Parlamentsgutachten klargestellt in welche Richtung wahrscheinlich auch eine Reise geht, wenn das dann bei ihr irgendwie vor Gericht landet, insofern ja eine äh wahrscheinlich,
Schneller Erfolg der GF, der nur auf den ersten Blick so ein bisschen,
Lapidar erscheint, aber eben auch wichtig ist, dass man da mal Rechtssicherheit äh erlangt und äh diesen diesen Einsatz da mal in die rechtlichen Bahnen lenkt,
dieser Twitter konnten.
Zumal dieser Twitter-Journalismus ja auch immer mehr um sich greift. Schlimm. Schlimm. Schlimm.
Schlimm. Schlimm ist das. So, schlimm ist auch, dass wir hier so maßlos überziehen, aber eins haben wir noch.
Telekom, Austria, österreichischer Telekommunikationsprovider, ähm hat.
Äh von vierzehntausend Kunden die Verkehrsdaten nicht fristgerecht gelöscht.
Und da gab's dann also einen Anwalt, der die bei der äh Datenschutzbehörde angezeigt hat und äh seiner Anzeige eine siebenhundert Seiten lange Liste betroffener Kunden mit eingereicht hat und diese Kunden.
Hatten sich
bei A eins über die Leistung oder Abrechnung beschwert und bei der Bearbeitung haben die Mitarbeiter dann Nutzungsprofile
zusammengestellt und da wurden dann irgendwie auch die Standorte und mit der der genutzten Zellen und mit wem sie telefoniert haben und so weiter gespeichert.
Und die das laut Telekommunikationsgesetz von zweitausenddrei müssen die solche Daten, also,
nicht für die Rechnung erforderlichen Verkehrsdaten sofort löschen. Ähm! Drei Monate nach der Rechnungsstellung und so weiter. Jetzt wurde das aber, wurden diese Daten da eben aufbewahrt und zwar teilweise über Jahre.
Und äh jetzt äh droht der.
Der Telekom Austria für dieses für diesen Verstoß gegen das Datenschutzgesetz eine Verwaltungsstrafe von zweihundertachtzehn.
Euro.
Wo wie kein tausen.
Maximal zweihundertachtzehn. Zwischen sieben und zweihundertachtzehn Euro äh Strafe. Wer auch immer,
die Missstände aus äh aufgedeckt haben, dürfte. Whisleblower oder was, der gesagt hat, ich finde hier diese ganzen Verkehrsdaten von all diesen Leuten.
Äh dem drohen bis zu
fünfundzwanzigtausend Euro Verwaltungsstrafe. Ich will das nur mal als Beispiel nennen dafür warum Datenschutzverletzungen eben äh immer noch als Kavaliersdelikte gelten und ja auch als solche ähm.
In der Öffentlichkeit zunimmt behandelt werden, zweihundertachtzehn Euro ist natürlich äh herbe. Da muss man gucken, ob die Portokasse,
noch so viel äh Guthaben aufweist.
Oh, könnte eng werden.
Ja. Und mit diesem herzlichen Lacher wenden wir uns den Termin zu.
Vom zweiten bis vierten Mai zweitausendachtzehn findet in Berlin in der Station wieder die Republika statt. Ähm,
Was gibt's dazu noch zu sagen? Ist wahrscheinlich inzwischen allen bekannt. Die große,
Konferenz mit sieben Vorträgen gleichzeitig und großer Sause und paar tausend Besuchern in Berlin in der Station.
Ich werde am zweiten Mai kurz da sein für ein Panel,
Für der normalerweise nie ein Panel zusagen, aber wenn Chris Stöcker mich einlädt, dann bin ich dabei. Ähm ehemalige Netzwerkleiter Spiegel Online.
Ist ja wahrscheinlich auch nicht nur so ein reines Männerpanel.
Nein, das ist kein reines Männerpanel, das war übrigens bei der Republika auch äh.
Schon immer schon Politik.
Wir haben das im CFP schon geschrieben, so dass irgendwie keine Penispanäle haben woll.
Ordentlich. Ja und äh offenbar war es auch noch ein weiteren Bedarf gibt. Die Motivationslage ist mir noch nicht so hundertprozentig klar
wird der Kernrepublika vom zweiten bis vierten Mai dann noch am fünften Mai noch eine weitere Veranstaltung folgen. Fast am gleichen Ort, nämlich auch an der Station Berlin, aber
draußen
Vermute mal innen wird dann schon alles abgebaut werden, aber draußen gibt's dann so eine Art Open Air und das Ganze läuft unter dem Namen Netz fest. Wo ja angeblich auch noch äh Livemusik spannende Vorträge und äh
ein vielfältiges Rahmenprogramm für die ganze Familie stattfinden wird, was auch immer das heißt. Na ja okay, also was weiß ich, Frittenstände und Bratwurst scheint wohl
äh sicher zu sein.
Bei der Republika gibt's auch noch.
Äh wir wissen noch nicht so ganz genau, was sich dahinter äh verbirgt. Vielleicht ähm soll hier einer äh
potenziellen Entfremdung entgegen gearbeitet werden. Ich äh kann hier nur vermuten, wir haben da noch keine tiefen Einblicke, aber da wir auch keine sonstigen Termine gemeldet bekommen von euch.
Touristisch rechtzeitig. Ähm ja, gibt's halt nur magere Kost und äh von daher,
Kommen wir dann auch langsam zum Ende. Das nimmt ja hier schon wirklich Freakshow äh Ausmaße an.
Ja, nee, das kann man so nicht mehr weitermachen. Aber jetzt Politik ist halt auch eine Free Show.
Gott, jetzt habe ich schon zwei Freakshows. Na ja, so ist es dann nun mal. Ähm nichtsdestotrotz.
Hoffen wir äh euch gut informiert zu haben.
Auf unserer Art, wie wir es immer so machen, treiben und halten, hoffen auch noch ein paar Überraschungen für euch bereit zu haben im Laufe dieses Jahres. Da gibt's aber jetzt noch nichts zu erzählen und.
Ich danke noch dem Joachim.
Ja und ich danke wie immer pauschal allen anderen außer Joachim,
für die fortwährende Unterstützung in finanzieller und motivationeller äh Art und Natur. Wie ihr es immer treibt und macht und äh gut macht und,
das war's dann. Jetzt gibt's noch ein bisschen Bonusdreck und dann sehen wir uns nächste Woche wieder. Bis bald.
Ciao ciao.